at his
latest press event i suppose we heard
one of the most powerful statements from
the president about building that wall
strangely it wasn't donald trump it was
joe biden who said he wants to
restart construction on the wall because
there's been an ongoing crisis at the
border that's been exacerbated by
joe biden himself talk about amazing
hypocrisy and an amazing i told you so
like what do you say to all these people
who voted for biden
where it's like oh you know all that
stuff trump was doing turns out it was
working
and then you voted for biden to do
something else and within a few months
he realized what trump was doing was
working
now you got the b team because donald
trump compared to joe biden was it i
hate to say it but
donald trump was the a team now you get
the b team so joe biden's
only recourse i suppose is to do exactly
what trump was doing it's amazing
he's actually going back on on all of
their promises he said
we're not gonna build that wall we're
gonna we're gonna you know we're gonna
stop building it
beto o'rourke actually said tear the
wall down all the activists were like
shut down these child migrant facilities
we had aoc saying these are
concentration camps
and it's not my opinion it's expert
analysis where's she at now
she's tweeting that concentration camps
are actually just
influx facilities with controversial
records
boy that's one way to put it amazing
we were only a few months in and joe
biden has already realized that trump
was right how
incredible is that so we're going to
talk about this among other things
there's another really funny story
apparently
jordan peterson is is like the basis for
the red skull
in the new captain america comic which
for some reason these these woke
leftists
love defending nazis it's the weirdest
thing of course
they'll call it conservative nazi but
when it comes to literal nazis like the
red skull they're like
let's let's model them after jordan
peterson who is a mainstream and popular
personality
among regular people sure they might try
and claim that jordan peterson is
fringe or whatever but if you actually
look at jordan peterson and the coverage
he's gotten
new york times bestseller new book
coming out he's appeared on talk shows
not super political not super
controversial that's that's what they're
claiming is the bad guy
that's creepy stuff we'll talk about it
joining us today is josie
the red-headed libertarian hi thank you
for having me yeah do you want to just
give a quick little introduction
my name is josie and i am on twitter at
the
e-t-r-h-l and
um you're a libertarian i'm
i'm a ron paul libertarian i'm a real
libertarian
not any of that l.p crap
those are fighting words the libertarian
party was yelling at me the libertarian
party of texas was young at me
remember remember when joe jorgensen
tweeted it's not enough to not be racist
we must actively be anti-racist you know
i got blamed for that
you got blamed i got blamed for that i
have nothing to do with
that abomination but um someone
someone thought that i tweeted that for
some reason i have no idea who tweeted
that i don't know i don't care who
tweeted joe jorgensen tweeted it
no it was people who work for her right
right right oh they thought
so they thought i worked for her and i
tweeted and it was a rumor that i
i tweeted i tweeted that and i'm like i
that that's bizarre but yeah so i just
loved the idea of the libertarian party
telling people what they must do
yeah that's kind of the opposite of what
you're supposed to be you know preaching
like remember when that guy got on stage
and took his clothes off
yeah yeah they were partying great
devolved libertarian party oh my god
were they at one point
awesome like regular libertarians yeah
they used to be normal
now they're not normal yeah
now there was like apparently a couple
years ago there was a debate over
whether or not
an individual should be allowed to sell
drugs to kids oh yeah austin peterson
shout out
yeah yeah his argument no that was him
he said
no you know everybody booed him
they booed him when he said no when he
said no because he wouldn't sell the
drugs to the kids
like that's a line no i mean there's
like dude there's there's things that
that the libertarian party nowadays
skews
to the point where like i don't even
like to associate with it you know i
started this as
a ron paul libertarian a small l you
know understanding uh property rights
self-ownership
personal responsibility accountability
and the non-aggression principle
and it's it's devolved into this
like marxist like all the
talking points um how weird is that
right
it's like the worst part of wokeness but
with like pro corporate authority
opposite and so so if you think about
for instance like we want to abolish the
borders that's right out of the
communist
manifesto that's chapter two you can go
ahead and get it from the library or
your
marxist neighbor and read it um chapter
two it talks about abolishing
nations abolishing borders taking that
stuff down and it's like
you know there should be a path to
immigration and easy past immigration
you should
you know like show up say hi i'm a stone
mason here's my family
i fled venezuela please let me in they
go all right let's do fingerprints oh
you're not you're not a terrible person
go in
you can't get benefits for replacement
yes you know figuring out where they can
survive and not be tossed randomly into
a gutter is one of the big problems
yes so all the open borders people it's
like send them to the ghetto
like no you want to fix that so we'll
rag on the libertarian party
uh we got we got ian what up everybody
he is wearing a brown shirt in crossfit
hanging out with this awesome uh
periodic table of the elements with a
piece of each element
you know except for the radioactive ones
yeah few other choice elements but
there's
literally a piece of each each element
in this acrylic it's very but is it
is do do does every single radio
development emit gamma waves
i don't know because it's the alpha and
beta particles i guess i guess they emit
gamma radiation that's you know i don't
know enough about it you're the chemist
though
me i'm not yeah well we also got lydia
press buttons i am pushing buttons in
the corner i'm sour patch lids and
josie's hair makes my hair look
completely brown not red at all so i'm
enjoying this red-haired company
we absolutely must talk about job joe
biden wanting to build that well before
we do
my friends smash that like button
subscribe hit that notification bell we
are so close to 1 million subscribers
and with your help we will get there
that's
so thank you all so much if you're
listening on itunes or spotify leave us
a good review because it helps as well
but go to timcast.com first and foremost
become a member to get access to members
only exclusive posts
even full full episodes we've got a huge
library of content
that we've been expanding and building
up now we're doing about four per week
which means
we've been doing this for a few months
there's probably several dozen videos
that you could watch from all of your fa
your favorite guests like james o'keefe
like sheamus from freedom tunes and jack
murphy and even michael malus
and you will get that if you come if you
become a member but becoming a member
helps support the show in the event that
we get banned
this is where we will have all of our
content and uh we had to set it up
because as you've as you've seen with
like steven crowder for instance yeah
they're
they're getting ban happy and it's
possible but we got we have a bunch of
really awesome stuff in the works i'm
having uh pitch meetings with people
about doing shows and doing movies and
just actual
content so we might actually have a
content library of tv shows and stuff
should be a lot of fun again timcast.com
and again smash the like button share
the podcast let's talk about biden bill
netwall
we have the story from the daily mail
biden now wants to restart construction
on trump's border wall to plug the gaps
with kids camps way over capacity and a
new surge of migrants coming from
guatemala
this is amazing joe biden actually
shut down the construction as soon as he
gets in because
people like joe biden and the people who
voted for him look
i'm trying to be nice i'll be respectful
i understand a lot of people just didn't
know what they were voting for when they
voted for biden
they hear something there's no logical
basis to it it's just an emotional
reaction
the wall is racist donald trump is the
cheeto dictator so the wall must be
stopped
so biden gets in and goes yeah come on
yo we're gonna stop the wall
you gotta you gotta you know get the
straight razor in the barrel and then
bang it on the
the fence and make it come down and then
he stops construction
and then all of a sudden we're dealing
with this massive border crisis why
because biden basically signaled to all
of these
individuals in other countries open for
business
what did biden say moratorium on
deportations for 100 days he lost that
fight but he still said it
so these people are thinking under trump
you know they're going to throw you out
at least you can try and get some media
pity
under joe biden so here they come now
joe biden has no choice
but to reopen the child detention
centers he's putting children
under bridges in mcallen texas sleeping
in dirt
and now he's going to rebuild the wall i
got to say i wonder if the trump
supporter's gonna be like
all right we'll take the win on that one
you know we were worried we weren't
gonna get the wall and now trump's gonna
build the wall so uh
how very um that's strong leadership
from joe biden right
yeah you know he actually said that he
inherited this crisis it was exactly
like this we just didn't hear about it
because the media
never would have smeared donald trump
that's right that's right never
is it because of like a global recession
that we're getting this influx of
migrants or have we always well so there
there is there are seasonal waves that's
true and joe biden tried claiming uh
there's no crisis you know it's it's a
seasonal wave come on man
and what's actually happening because
abc i think abc and nbc
uh journalists interviewed some illegal
immigrants who are like
uh it's cause joe biden says he's gonna
be nice
and he's giving us an opportunity to
come so you actually had i can't
remember who it was
i think it might have been cnn where
they were like you can't deny this
you actually have no no i'm sorry it was
uh jonathan carl
i think he was talking to brian stelter
brian shelter of cnn was like these are
right-wing talking points
and this guy from abc is like no it
isn't our reporter went down and
the illegal immigrant said it's because
of biden
well there you go you vote for a guy who
screws it up and now the best he can
offer is
trying to do what trump was already
doing it is true that the words of the
president have resounding
impact like when trump was like get him
out of here hit that guy or something at
a rally
and then you saw starting to see this
wave of people punching people he said
something like
you know i would hit him and you know
i'll pay the legal fees or something
like that someone decked a guy at one of
his rallies so it does and if biden
mentioned that even in passing i can
imagine it would definitely be well
affecting people so
there's you know there's one of the big
problems with trump during his
presidency but he he did
stop that that was early in his
campaigns and then he was like no no we
can't do that we'll let the police
handle it because he realized like
no i can't tell people to do something
like that or or support anyway
but with donald i'm sorry i think some
of that was going from being a celebrity
you know celebrity businessman like well
liked guy friends of everybody the first
time he was ever booed was going down
that escalator never been booed in his
life
um so i think a lot of that was how he
would have behaved as you know
a personality and then being like oh my
gosh i'm i'm running for president i
can't i can't say things like that
anymore
however because of things like that
imagine what these other countries must
have been thinking
when it's like imagine you're you know
like iran or something
and they're like we need you to go and
have this meeting with donald trump and
the guy goes
what am i gonna say that guy that's
crazy no matter what i say he's gonna be
yelling at me it's like
i'm not getting anything done and so all
of these countries were probably on
edge every time they would meet with
trump or have to meet with the u.s
because they're like
trump is just gonna demand and there's
nothing you can do to convince the guy
now they got sleepy joe now they're all
laughing and high-fiving each other and
they're like yes
so imagine what how everyone is feeling
you've got a lot of
people who want to come to come to this
country and i said this before i'll say
it again cause i love saying it
i have infinitely more respect for
illegal immigrants
who are willing to crawl through you
know walk through vast swathes of desert
risking their lives going on thousand
mile journey because they think america
is that awesome
as opposed to these woke leftists who
are like america is racist and awful
our health care is awful it's like okay
tell that to the people who are dying to
come here
who are like surging at the border
so i digress these people want to come
they're regular people they clearly see
the rhetoric of donald trump was
very extreme we're going to send them
back you got to stay we're going to
build a wall and they're like
you could risk this huge journey and
they're gonna they're gonna kick you out
new mexico
with the remaining mexico policy now
with joe biden it's like
door's open let's roll
that's right how much more of the wall
do they have well
biden wants to plug up some gaps so like
how complete is it are you guys familiar
with it
uh it's about i think last the last
number i read was like seven hundred
miles
i think was it seven hundred no that's
correct yeah and what what they tried
doing was smearing trump by saying
like uh trump proposed a big beautiful
wall
30-foot concrete from sea to shining sea
and they were like you're not going to
build 2 000 whatever miles of wall
then what happens is when trump gets in
and he finally gets the funding
he starts reinforcing select areas where
there's
serious problems trafficking smuggling
etc and then they started claiming
trump's only replacing existing wall
which was the craziest lie
because the wall at the womb doing air
quotes was like
two pieces like two two by fours and an
x shape with another two by four on did
you guys ever see the wall with your own
eyes
i've just seen pictures of of both i
went to tijuana
south they're right by uh south south
california and man it was
junk it was like post totally going out
into the water like
40 walk around like you could just swim
out around it and go mm-hmm
yeah i've been i was uh i've been to
various points on the border recently in
the past few years i was in
uh mexicali and calexico i think the
city's name
and it's it's really amazing how it's
actually
in in some ways rather porous legally
like people just walk back and forth
every single day like normal so like
some people from mexico are like they
walk up and they're like here's my id
it's like what are you coming for i'm
going shopping have a nice day sir and
they walk into the u.s they go shopping
and they go home where are you going i'm
going home have a nice day sir
but yeah you could see the wall and we
went a little further out
and you could see the uh i can't
remember exactly what it
it's like fencing you see the trucks
driving along it well so what happened
was donald trump wanted a big concrete
wall
and i guess cbp and ice they were like
cbp said you don't want a wall because
we need to see on the other side of it
so they're like what if we do like
fencing and then a wall on top and like
we need to see on the other side of it
they make windows
like you can walk through the wall yeah
yeah just open like a regular old window
with a sliding glass doors
sliding glasses blocks on them well so
so so the media claims trump didn't
build the wall mexico obviously didn't
pay for it trump tried claiming the
trade deal was gonna you know pay for it
over
but uh he built select secure fencing
triple layered in some areas
so you've got one big fence a smaller
fence and a smaller fence
razor wire and cbp vehicles driving in
between the two
particularly secure well they were doing
construction
joe biden stopped it and then boom
border prices yeah
i heard that most migrants come in uh
via airplane i don't think that i don't
think it's most
oh but i think it's a lot okay they're
like flying to chicago
well they they fly in on tourist visas
and then stay yeah
they're never leave yeah there are a
bunch of other issues too that that are
legit like um
what do they call it uh like what is it
called pregnancy tourism or something
like that oh yeah birthday birth
terrorism yeah oh
so we're just trying to have a baby yeah
yeah so
a woman will be you know on the verge of
giving birth
she'll fly here you get three to six
months depending on what your visa is
and they just wait have the kid the
kid's a citizen it could be what do you
guys think should be like the criteria
of
immigrating to the united states uh
hunger games
if you you've got to compete and the
only the person who survives gets the
citizenship
it obviously i'll i'll i'll start it off
i think i think they should speak
english
100 you need that's my number one
really why because otherwise i just want
people to assimilate into the culture
that that is a good point assimilation
is a good point i wonder maybe if they
should
commit just to learning to speak english
like you know like
something something on those lines as
opposed to already knowing the english
wouldn't
i might have the means to learn it i i
understand the point but i kind of feel
like maybe americans should learn
more languages too and so that's racist
saying that americans should learn more
languages you know it's a cultural
language
appropriation yes we speak english if we
learn spanish it's cultural
appropriation i read that somewhere
so it must be true remember those ladies
who were making tacos in
portland or whatever yeah and they got
shut down and the story was like they
would look through the windows at
mexican restaurants to like see how
things were done and that was stealing
and i'm like dude
most of these restaurants just like they
have the abuelita making the
corn tortillas in front of everybody to
show you it's like real fresh
and it's just it's like corn flour and
water you know what i mean and you just
like
and you put on the thing it's just
authentic when you've got the nice
little your grandma she's making it for
you
i went to one place it was awesome right
when you walk in there's like the
the grill and there was a little you
know mexican grandmother and she's
smiling and waving and she's making
tortillas and i was like
this is going to be the best taco i've
ever had but apparently i'm not supposed
to like that
it's crazy like you you have these these
restaurants and they're like we want
people to
you know enjoy this stuff anyway going
back to the main point
dude look we have mexican restaurants
all over the u.s it becomes a part of
our culture with a great american
melting pot
i do get your point about speaking
english because if people can't talk to
each other it's hard for them to work
together
so i saw that when i went to sweden when
you had the somali migrants and refugees
from 20 years ago
when they weren't properly integrated
they created their sort of
own community that didn't work properly
with the swedish you know like community
and so it created poverty it created
poverty it bred crime
and then the swedes were super racist
and they were like oh those people are
are bad and it's like dude you took
people from a war-torn country
who are desperate good for you i
appreciate that that's a good thing to
do
but you then just dropped them in a city
center somewhere and
left and these people had no idea how to
speak swedish or get jobs
what were they supposed to do you can't
just do that
saving the people was a great idea but
it's it's like half-assed
and that's what's happening now with the
left and the open borders people they're
like let them come in
it's like okay after they come in and
there's 90 miles of desert what do we do
next
i don't know when cbp picks up this kid
and he's sick and dies they blame cbp
for it should they just let the kid die
in the desert
they give you these half answers they're
emotional there was like there was one
group of people
that put food and water randomly out in
the desert and they got arrested for it
for littering and it was this big thing
on the left where they're like
how awful are police it's so insane
they're trying to save migrants i'm like
dude
you can't go into the desert and just
put food and water on the ground and
think you're feeding someone
animals will come or you're just quite
literally putting garbage out that no
one's gonna eat
it's the craziest thing emotional uh
emotional responses
and now here we are months out and at
least joe biden's not tweeting mean
things
refugees i i find a little different i
would be okay letting refugees in where
regardless of the language they speak
because that's a that's a different
situation but immigration
that's that's where i start to draw the
line economic migration i i hear you're
saying
i guess i guess the issue is like
in the place where i grew up everyone
spoke polish some people didn't even
speak english
you know what i mean so there there are
issues of integration if a large
portion of an area can't communicate
with like the gas station attendant
what about uh ilhan's district dearborn
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no she's not dear boy that's
what you're supposed to see that's sorry
i'm just totally across that yes
um so but i'm thinking about dearborn
i think dearborn michigan it's
pretty much like you heavily it's it's
like you oh and dear feel like you're
going through another country when you
go through dearborn
but they speak english enough yeah and
so it works like i went to
i've been a dearborn a couple times yeah
and a lot of the businesses it's written
so they've assimilated i've never seen
it i've just
we were talking about um the swedish
community and i was wondering if
america had one i would say it was very
similar in that you go there
and or at least when i went there there
are areas where everything's in arabic
and you go to a restaurant but they can
speak english and i had a great time i
would be completely honest
i understand maybe there are some
concerns you know
you know about maybe gangs or extremists
or whatever when i went there
went to a car wash everybody was really
nice went out to eat we went and got
mediterranean food was amazing it was
like legit made by people who knew how
to make
you know falafel and hummus and all that
good stuff so
they're i don't know it's it is an issue
of
how can one community work with another
community with a greater community
if they don't understand each other but
i'm not entirely convinced that
that can't be navigated somehow like
it's it's the worst thing in the world
you know what i mean
i i don't think people need to i'll put
it this way
i don't think they need to be fluent in
english they need to be able to
communicate we need to be able to
communicate communicate with each other
to a certain degree
so i don't know how you solve for that i
do i do agree with you on the refugee
point though
economic migrants who are coming here
for work and for jobs
should be able to interact and and work
with other people and that requires
probably a base basic level of uh
english
because we are a predominantly speaking
country you know
yeah yeah it's good to be able to work
but i also think there's a huge part of
life that is not work i
basically live for my work i really
enjoy working and i like being able to
talk to all you guys
but at the same time if you want to be
able to actually be a part of the
culture that you're in you have to be
able to speak well enough
in the language that whatever country
that you're in that you have to be able
to like go out and meet in groups you
have to be able to meet other people who
already live there
i do think that fluency is a huge
benefit to people who come to the us
i wonder if this um multiculturalism
is it's something that's been in america
for a long time and i wonder if
it's one of the reasons we see things in
the united states we don't see in other
parts of the world
in the same levels so actually that that
probably makes no sense
i was going to say like when you look at
certain police brutality instances
it's interesting if you go to a country
like sweden or norway which are
overwhelmingly white and they say oh but
we don't have these things and i'm like
perhaps there's a
you know race plays a role and there's
like some kind of racism that can go in
any direction
that doesn't exist in a homogenous
homogeneous community where they all
agree speak the same language do the
same thing
so it's not necessarily about race it's
about i guess familiarity
but i i guess my point was that in the
united states like
there are segregated neighborhoods all
over chicago it's it's all totally
segregated no joke you cross
you go from archer on the south side you
go past cicero and the billboards are
now in spanish
you go the other direction and you got a
bunch of signs in polish
so how are these people going to you
know interact work with each other when
they're just like very distinct and
separate
culturally morally and linguistically
i feel like that could lead to an
inability for people to come together
and work together for sure
familiarity's key like if this this
isn't a race war
if anything it's like a a class war or
familiar
like you you you tend to be afraid of
what you don't understand the unknown
you know and language plays directly
into that and and a bias towards the in
group
so if you're an english-speaking
american you have a bias towards
people who are like you and those within
you know the polish community
in chicago aren't going to be able to
branch out and work their their
their jobs are in their community that's
why their community
there's no way to go up they're kind of
stuck in that
in that circle there's there's no
opportunities outside because you don't
speak the language but the older
generation
so what happens is the kids all speak
english like luke for instance
you know he's really he was on the show
for a little bit and then he just
abandoned us yeah
you know because he's he's a cold
callous individual
mexico he went to florida i guess but uh
but he was born in poland he moves here
he he grows up speaking english
he talked about how it was not so easy
for him because when he came here he
didn't
but then he did and now he's you know
extremely in my opinion extremely
important american defending american
values
so that's why i'm like i'm not super
concerned necessarily with
you know people coming here who don't
speak the language if they can function
and they can work
and they can you know be a part of the
community their kids will grow up and
it's really just about if we're doing a
good jo doing right by our kids and
teaching them
you know important values however i
guess that's that's something we're
doing entirely at this point a lot of
people don't want to have kids
they're talking about oh i can't raise a
kid in this environment and it's like
if you don't have kids then who's gonna
have kids it's like idiocracy you know
well a lot of it too
they're they're excusing themselves to
be able to extend their own childhood
yeah you know a lot of it is not that
they they don't want kids maybe in a
different
life they'd want kids but right now
they're very it's it's a me generation
it's very it's the most selfish
generation
i think i think the idea of childhood is
a modern creation
so it's interesting when i remember who
was a republican was like kids need
jobs and then the democrats were like
you want to go back to the 1900s putting
kids in factories and it's like
no but kids should do work
right but more than that like uh i think
kids should
paper spend more time seeing what their
parents do for a living
understanding the real world and we
should be treating kids like adults
the problem is as generation of
generation has has
you know come and gone it seems like
it used to be if you had a kid the kid
had to grow up fast there was war there
was death there was famine
stop crying you're 13 you're a man now
and that's like pretty brutal and we're
like nah like we want to be
like kind of chill but we keep pampering
the next generation oh yeah now it's
like kids are
i say kids now you got people who are 26
years old and they're like
just getting out of college and they've
never had a job in their lives it's like
dude you're 26.
amazing i i learned how to cook when i
was 14. i didn't even realize this i
just realized this couple days ago
because i'm i'm
a bit of a chef a cook i love cooking i
love the smell making things
and i used to work at a chicken shack
when i was 14. i think that directly
contributed to my ability to understand
food i didn't even think of that but
you gotta you gotta learn teach you
learn young too when i went to south
america the kids would like be boat
captains at the age of nine you'd go
down the
the amazon with the italian they'd be
like full on running the show
nine-year-olds imagine being like 15
from one of these countries you come to
the united states and you've been a boat
captain running your own business
and then you come here and you see all
these 15 year olds like sitting around
picking their nose and you're like wow
what are you doing
how are these people gonna like you know
what it is man
it is it is capital city hunger games
man affluenza
it is yeah yeah americans in general are
suffering from affluenza actually a
judge
adjudicated that affluenza was a thing
right but listen
that's like the specific case it's kind
of like i roll my eyes
that ruling's ridiculous but think about
americans in general 15 year old 16 year
old 17 18 year olds
who don't have jobs and never did i had
a job at 14
and before that i was volunteer at the
ymca what was your job of 14
uh fast food perfect yep 14 14.
but how are you how are you legally
allowed to do that because you could
work at 14. i'm
i'm older than i look like a worker's
permit yeah when did they change the law
to be that you had to be 16
shortly after i started working oh even
with a workers permit
i was able to i don't know actually i
didn't get a worker's permit i worked in
my family business
oh yeah when i was really young so yeah
and a lot of workers at the table
kids like i mean i come from a family a
lot of them live up in
pearl vermont and they all own farms and
those kids have been you know
collected eggs from the chicken since
they were five you know you got a
first job yeah you gotta you gotta have
a sort of
responsibility a personal responsibility
to become a you know well-rounded person
when you don't you end up with a bunch
of woke me first
you lack you end up lacking
responsibility and accountability and
that's kind of why the
america's in chaos right now no one
takes any responsibility for what they
do
that's why it's crazy to me when when
people come over off gas and they'll be
like
they'll look at my work schedule and be
like you're crazy and i'm like
i think you're crazy man like no offense
to some of these people but like
i i used to work every weekend as well
now weekend is partially administrative
with some time off to relax go out to
eat or whatever
but it's like i work you know eight to
four and then i work seven to eleven
every day and in between all i'm doing
is like eating or exercising it's like
all of my time is consumed
and i'm like what would i do if i wasn't
working like what do you do for fun
i don't know like what do you mean you
don't know do you like just sit there
yeah meditation no no you blank out
you blanked your mind it's awesome
that's weird you get your weird to me
regeneration
i don't know about that yeah i think you
have a hobby and you do your hobby
and i mean you raise your family if you
have a family
yeah i mean i know there's a lot of
people without purpose
and so that's that's kind of a cancer
right now in america too because
they think they find a purpose is
something you just want to commit your
life to like a lot of people
especially the older generations their
purpose is their family
they have you know they've set money
aside they just don't on their family
they
they love their family they spend time
with their family but you get a younger
generation and
their purpose is the next big drama
and that's their they commit their whole
life to this this is they're going to go
to
protest the wall and that's just their
that's their purpose that's their whole
life they put everything into it until
that passes and their purpose is gone so
then they have that drop
speaking of purpose oh yeah let's talk
about this story from bounding into
comics
excellent marvel comics author tom
nahisi coates compares
jordan peterson to the red skull in the
latest issue of captain america
and this plays into purpose
accountability responsibility
and for some reason the woke left
desperately trying to defend nazi
ideology probably because
they share that ideology to a great
degree those that aren't familiar
the red skull is quite literally a nazi
scientist in the captain america comic
he was the villain for captain america
and it was written when you know like
world war ii and stuff
so uh red skulls and nazi in this latest
iteration
the red skull is apparently a youtube
self-help guru
who is telling people to like the 10
rules for life or something
and i just love the idea how insane this
comic is let me see if i can uh
i'll pull up yeah here it is right here
check it out captain america he's in
this hospital and he says
so let me guess your brother he
disappears into the internet
and when he comes back out he can't stop
talking about his new theory of the
world
and that theory comes from one man the
red skull
and look at this laptop chaos and order
carl luger's genius
the feminist trap and it's the red skull
saying 10
rules for life wow very obviously jordan
peterson
could you imagine if like the internet
actually allowed
a former nazi scientist to go on and
preach like extremism
they barely allow conservatives to say
learn to code
like they're going to allow the red
skull on the internet mm-hmm is this
like real
is it real this is not real
[Laughter]
look dude when listen this is important
when you
live the most privileged pampered
affluenza life
and then along comes a psychologist
who's like okay clean your room
that's violence it's painful no no but
seriously
these people are wads of cookie dough
they are they are puffy little pink
marshmallows
that you touch them slightly and leaves
a dent and they start screaming
because they've never experienced
sensation of touch before so you get
someone like jordan peterson who's like
clean your room and it's like how dare
you tell me to do
work work is not real it's offensive
genuinely i believe these people feel
physical pain
when someone calls them a name because
they've never experienced it before
it's like for the first time in their
life they're feeling a negative emotion
because someone doesn't like them
these are people who grow up and they're
given a trophy for everything they go to
school
and then you know they answer the
question wrong that's okay here's your
trophy and they're like yes
there's my dopamine rush get it wrong
you get the award anyway
now they're older and they finally
graduate college outside of their bubble
you know bubble and then they're like
walking down the street and some guy
goes
you suck and they go and they just like
drop to their knees and like start
hyperventilating
or jordan peterson writes a book where
he's like if you want to be better
take responsibility for yourself stand
up straight stand up straight don't let
anyone ride your back
yeah that's it he's amazing clinical
psychologist professor
vocal advocate for human rights uh
brilliant and red skull wow and
apparently the reds and a nazi scientist
good job jordan can you imagine like
captain america
his personas opposed to classical
liberalism and responsibility
it's the antithesis right it's like it's
like captain america may as well be
hydra at this point
although they did that at one point i
guess who wrote that comic tanahisi
coates that's like a an activist a
critical oh it's an activist who's
writing marvel comics
yeah uh a cult uh occultist a journalist
racist i would say you know they try to
use language for all their arguments
what's what's the i don't say nazi you
know they like to use that word but it's
become rather
meaningless and like they call jordan
peterson and nazi and it's like he's a
he he complains about the nazis and he's
like he's a classical liberal
psychologist who tells people to be
responsible for themselves
that's like not nazism so these people
are something very similar
they hold a lot of the same belief
structures and values right they're
pro-segregation
they like uh ebermex candy for instance
said the only solution to past
discrimination is present discrimination
which is like identitarianism which
overlaps greatly with the nazi ideology
and you have classical liberals who are
like be responsible for yourself
you know the rights are for the
individual and things like that
they're trying to villainize those who
believe in freedom and liberty
because they're authoritarians it's like
you know and they want people to bow to
their cult
so it's no surprise they're trying to
liken
jordan peters into the red skull the
crazy thing about it though is what
they're effectively doing
is they're making nazis look good which
is the creepiest thing about it
jordan peterson's popular he's a famous
guy he's a mainstream personality
the left might call him controversial
but he appears on talk shows talk shows
about a variety of issues
so for them to be like the red skull is
a nazi and like this is you know jordan
peterson it's like
are you trying to make make it look like
nazis are mainstream and accepted in
society
apparently yes yes because they want to
use that as a boogeyman
so they soften the the view and they
defend it
so over at the comic let's i'll show you
a little bit more oh yeah
this guy says captain america says it's
all the sa it's the same for all of them
young men weak looking for purpose i
found the flag you found the badge
they found the skull he tells them what
they've always longed to hear
that they are secretly great that the
whole world is against them
that if they're truly men they'll fight
back and bingo that's their purpose
that's what they live for
and that's what they'll die for it's
kind of funny this idea that like
individualists are more likely to die
for their ideals than a collectivist
i kind of don't know if that's true you
know what i mean like a communist is
going to be the hive is willing to
expend
the drones way more readily than the
individual the individual will
defend their lives you know to the last
foot
but maybe maybe individuals recognize
the importance of individual action
and that if they don't stand up no one
will whereas collectivists are like
someone else will do it why should i
have to
so yeah maybe i keep thinking that
the red skull and superman are going to
do a crossover
what uh michael malus and jordan
peterson oh they did it
yeah a couple days ago it was a little
off topic where i want to get it out now
that jordan peterson is the red skull
yes yeah michael is superman don't have
enough interviews it is really dumb
i i'm almost aghast and yeah the left
can't mean they really can't yeah
there's more they say later at the
conclusion of the issue red skull's
followers proceed to overwhelm a wounded
captain america before he was rescued
from his attackers by an armored sharon
carter in turn red skull takes footage
of roger's defeat and proceeds to use it
in a propaganda video
appealing to the various racist and
terroristic groups who've taken up his
message by offering them a metaphorical
sword of
manhood he says what has happened to the
man of the world is truly one of the
great tragedies of our time
once the american man was a conqueror
now he is but a caretaker
and a caretaker of what he stands for
some
amorphous dream a dream of nothing but
what i offer you is more than just some
petty dream
more than a life of tending the hearth
no more shall women be summoned to fight
your battles
i offer steel i i offer steel for your
spine and iron for your gut
i offer you the sword of manhood
this sounds so cringy this sounds like a
take on his uh
jordan's explanation of the meek shall
inherit the earth meaning not the weak
uh what it actually means is that those
with a large weapon that choose not to
use it those are the meek and those are
the people that are
usually the most respected and the ones
that they have self-control
yes yep and obviously this guy destroyed
that message and
made it sound like he's trying to
weaponize people well that also
lets you know that he's he's a threat
his his words are a threat yep jordan
peterson is threatening to them that's
why they have to be like nope he's a
nazi and i'm going to meme about it
because i'm good at that
maybe i also kind of think that they're
just really dumb yeah
and so they need something to be a
villain and they don't know so they
choose jordan peterson and it literally
makes no sense
because if you actually look at jordan
peterson he's like nazis are bad
and they're like well that clearly means
that jordan peterson's a nazi so i'm
guessing he probably
sat there and he's like all right who
are some um self-help
you know who who are some mainstream
conservative
um well everybody they don't like is
conservatives right
but you know who are like you know he's
pro-masculinity
so so who are some big voices that are
pro-masculine because masculinity is
evil right now they are feminizing the
military they want
nothing to do with with with masculinity
right now that's bad
it's all toxic all masculinity
masculinities so you think you wonder if
you sat there and they kind of went over
different mainstream you know men who
have a
podium and just landed on him by like a
roll the dice too
and we're like you know where does this
lead to
if our our comic books our movies are
telling men not to be masculine they're
saying max
masculinity is toxic and they're trying
to prop up people like brie larson who's
just like a really mean person
i imagine it's like idiocracy did
predict social justice you know
for those that have seen the movie you
guys have seen idiocracy right you know
part of it
the the idea is that evolution stopped
rewarding the strongest and simply
rewards those who reproduce the most
that's us so like stupid people are
having tons of kids and smart people are
like now is not the time so in 500 years
everyone's really dumb
however what they didn't account for is
wokeness so i'm imagining if all of
these media outlets are saying
be effeminate essentially don't be
masculine masculinity is wrong jordan
peterson's a bad guy
eventually you're going to get a bunch
of dudes who are the epitome of toxic
masculinity
and society is going to be a bunch of
wimpy frail scared and effeminate men
and then the strong men will just walk
and take over yep
no one's gonna do anything about it that
is one way
um also another different direction
would be like if if people start
creating new art forms new comic books
new a new
comic company comes out with a new set
of heroes that are legit
like more understandable and relatable
and we diverge
evolutionarily i don't think homo sapien
is the end of our
our route we're now gonna become robots
yeah some of us will become robotic
humans cybernetic some of us will become
psychic some of us will become like
more animal and some of us will live on
mars some of us will live in orbit with
large
larger bodies it's it's all kind of i
don't know that has to do with
comic books well some of these weird
critical race people might evolve into
some bizarre self-hating race of humans
i i really don't think that's a
possibility because that would take
hundreds of thousands of years for
divergence but also scale i think
technology's
speeding up our evolution right but
that's because we're incorporating
technology into our bodies
which could ultimately mean we transform
in some kind of robot creatures
in television television rapidly evolved
us but i want to say this in regards to
captain america and you mentioned new
comics and new movies and new shows
so one of the things i'm doing is
actually just i've been i've received a
few pitches for
tv shows and movies and stuff and we
might we're on the verge of basically
green lighting a comedy series which is
it's going to be on timecast.com i
imagine and we're just going to start
doing more of that
just making cultural stuff that's fun
funny it's not woke
it's not going to be culture war stuff
it's just going to be funny stuff it'll
probably poke fun at politics but i look
at this
who cares about captain america anymore
i gotta be honest no one like
dude it has been 70 years you know what
i mean like
at a certain point do they make new
comic books with new heroes and new arcs
and news stories
or do we just keep rebooting the same
characters and then just trying to make
it relevant for some reason
sorry dude i like the movies but here's
the thing about the mcu
they did three captain america movies
and then captain america did the
avengers they brought them all together
and then he's like i quit because at a
certain point they realized
captain america in the movie can't carry
on anymore
so then he goes back in time and boom
he's gone tony stark
he does a bunch of movies he obviously
three iron man movies the
the four avenger movies plus he was in
civil war
and then they were like robert downey
jr's run his course we can't keep using
iron man anymore
time for him to move on there'll be a
new one like they do with spider-man
sure
sure in the in the mcu they need a new
character
and they're they're they're bringing old
characters to life
they probably should have new characters
sure fine but at least in the mcu they
recognize
at a certain point we've exhausted this
character we retire them and
unfortunately the mcu is stanley
stanley made all almost all those
characters the hulk the thing i mean he
made it all fantastic i think they're
trying to maybe keep him alive too like
in spirit by keeping to you know
reboot his vision like one division just
came out
it was bad yeah i thought one division
was terrible
yeah did you see it i i watched it
through i didn't really have a strong
feeling i just got told i looked like
she just tortured yourself oh yeah you
do
yeah she's got that a lot she tortures 3
000 people and she's the good guy
and the first three episodes are just a
waste of time the first three episodes i
was like are we gonna keep watching this
i turned it off i just yeah we didn't
watch it and then i and then i kept
checking i kept like
waiting for social media posts and then
once i saw the show actually started
episode four i was like okay i'll watch
it now
and then i was kind of like they really
drag it out and waste your time
anyway look i digress uh we need we need
new characters
we need new stories we need new
heroes but i'll tell you i make new
characters new stories i'm not making it
for marvel that was stan lee's company
and you know what it is disney owns it
now stan lee and and
jack kirby and who else there was a jim
lee
i mean he did a lot of art there but
there was a hand job kirby
back in the day what did kirby do uh he
was one of he created a bunch of the
characters
so back in the day you had these these
these people and they were geniuses
they were they were visionaries they
were like i got an idea
it's this guy and when he gets mad he
turns into a big green monster
i believe he originally wasn't green i
think he was like gray or something then
they were like it doesn't the printing
isn't so great it's like heavy on the
ink or something
they changed them something like that
could be wrong but we grew up with that
being normal
we grew up with the ideas of these
superheroes just existing whereas
back then they were new and exciting and
it was like wow
superman you know superman originally
couldn't fly he could just jump really
high yeah
and then there was a period where you
could shoot a small superman from his
hand see they weren't they weren't
afraid to experiment
they're like let's do a comic where
superman can fire a superman from his
hand
and it's a little version of himself
probably the stupidest power i've ever
heard of
in comic book history stupid that's the
patronus
no the patronus is like a ball of of
hope and happiness
takes the shape of an animal so i think
respect to jk rowling for creating a
universe
that was not the same you see how
successful it was
that was incredibly successful we need
that stuff so here's what i think we end
up seeing
we have a bunch of regular people who
are not the geniuses
that are that were stan lee right and so
all they can do is take what someone
else made and move it around
and you end up with the lowest common
denominator this jordan peterson comic
is scraping the bottom of the barrel so
hard they've ripped through the bottom
layer of wood and they're just pulling
up
dirt they're not even getting barrel
anymore they just don't even realize
they're in the dirt right now nobody's
gonna eat that dude that's not food the
wood chips weren't food
you're done not only have you repurposed
captain america to a ridiculous degree
now you've made red skull a classical
liberal or something now
then he's alt-right i guess it's the
weirdest thing
to not only repurpose it to such a
degree that it's stupid
but then try and spin some mainstream
critique that doesn't even work
it's one thing if you were like the red
skull is still a nazi and he's got a
plan to steal all the gold from fort
knox and captain america stop him you're
like all right kind of generic i guess
but it's about a nazi and a guy fighting
him now it's like he's on the internet
making youtube videos and it's like wow
you have reached a whole new level of
stupidity there is a metaphor
between hitler and the youtube blogger
because hitler
basically was the first dictator to use
mass media and and
whip a nation into a frenzy with with
video propaganda
yeah but jordan peterson no
not true they could have picked any one
of these i think they just think that
jordan peterson's alt-right and they
equate alt-rights with the nazis
you know feel like they are close oh
gosh yeah definitely
definitely they're all about
collectivism and that's what the nazis
we're all about the fascism of that i
would highly advise watching jordan's
breakout video where he's speaking to a
group of students outside
about not forcing compelled speech yes
that's so
key and he was saying i've studied the
nazis i've studied the totalitarian
dictatorships of the communists it
begins with compelled speech
forcing people to use pronouns do not do
it well there was a guy who
uh was ordered to stop referring to his
child
as his daughter and he he got arrested
for that right i believe so
yeah it was a contempt of court i think
yeah so they were like you have to refer
to your child as
a boy and he was like no and then they
were like you're under arrest and then
jordan peterson was like
i told you and here we are doesn't it
seem like everything they do is a
reflection
like they talk about words projection
projection no reflection
listen listen okay listen listen so it's
a reflection because everything they say
they're like we don't want to be racist
all we're going to do is break up white
people and black people we don't want
any kind of hate speech all we're going
to do is separate a parent from its
child because
they use the wrong words there it's an
inversion of what they're telling us
they're like we want to be more kind and
more compassionate we're going to invite
people to cross a desert
and die and be trafficked for the sake
of our compassion well
that's why they say it's projection
because they're
complaining about what they do right
they're saying other people do this
awful thing okay
actually this makes me think about
libertarianism we're just talking about
this
why i'm reticent to force my political
views no matter how benevolent i think
they are on other people because
i know that is a phenomenon where we
reflect our own negativity or project or
refract or whatever
so i have this kind of hands-off
approach to what i think other people
should do
but sometimes there's such tragedy being
invoked
that i feel like i have to but so does
this guy and that's what he's doing with
this weird comic
like where do you draw i mean you're
you're explicitly literally actually i
want to use this to launch off something
you were talking about earlier
pertaining to the covet vaccine
passports oh yeah
and what you brought up something really
interesting that immediately was like
nah you can't be right by that so let me
let me do this first we got some some
some news from fox biden administration
will not require covid 19 vaccine
passports
white house says jensecki says there
will be no federal vaccinations database
now this is kind of to assuage the fears
of people who think the government's
going to mandate everybody get a vaccine
passport but they've
long said we can't do that we won't do
that the private sector will do that
which is still interesting because i'm
not sure the private sector can do that
because of a lot of laws that already
exist nondiscrimination laws the ada et
cetera
but i bring this up because we're
talking now about libertarianism
authoritarianism and what the government
is or isn't allowed to do and what we
should
should support so we'll do a hard segue
i guess and just
because i want you to bring this up you
mentioned that the coveted vaccine
passports are not legal
yeah because of so we have a right to
uh medical privacy but wait wait just
use the use the fancy buzzword oh
i'm i'm a god i gotta i gotta train you
wanna build the suspense build up the
sense all right so in 1973 the supreme
court
determined that um we are entitled to
uh to medical privacy and this was a
seven to two ruling
roe v wade determined that we are
entitled to medical privacy so roe v
wade
and the vaccine passports contradict
each other
what yeah interesting i don't know
in their ruling they said yes you are
your medical history is your private yes
it's they use the 14th amendment and
they said you're you are
the government cannot compel your you to
expose your medical history like
we can't control that we we can't you
you are entitled to
your medical history that's i've heard
the 14th amendment thing
but what would that stop a private
company i guess theoretically i guess
you could sue because a private company
has no right to your medical history
yeah denying you a service based on
medical history i mean they have to like
ada
it's it's it's crazy because
they could they'd have to go through you
to get it so they couldn't like go
through your doctor
because that'd be you know violation of
hipaa laws if they went through your
doctor
right um so they'd have to go through
you so it'd have to be up to you
to expose that but i feel like you could
bring a civil rights violation against
against them trying to make you expose
your medical rights to like buy milk
right there was a big thing with masks
where people started saying that they
had they were like they print out these
fake cards where it's like i have a
medical condition and protected under
the americans with disabilities act
and then they would go and walk around
and if someone is still like yeah to
wear a massive bag no i don't i have
this card
okay sure look the card's not real but i
think the idea actually is yeah
it's like imagine if a store was like
you can't come in here because your legs
are broken
you know we don't want to risk the
lawsuit if you fall and get hurt yep
so they say the same thing well we
require you to be vaccinated my medical
history and what i can or can't do is on
your business
and that goes in the bigger question of
they've said
if you're pregnant don't get the vaccine
they said if you uh if you have
allergies
you got to wait and you know joe biden
recently announced he's upped the
timeline so that every adult can get the
vaccine by april 19th
but what if your doctor tells you for
this reason we don't think you should
my doctor told me i shouldn't why is
that because i have a blood condition
interesting so now you're now you're
gonna go to a store and they're gonna
say
you need a vaccine passport and then you
can say it's none of your business
what my doctor told me and why is none
of your business
and what's going to what do you do i'll
probably get kicked out
well that would be a violation of the
americans with disabilities act wouldn't
it
yeah i mean i think the americans with
disabilities act is very specific
with what they consider a disability
um like like my my blood condition
isn't like i'm not sure what's on there
so i don't want to misquote it
but um i i know i know i
i couldn't get disability or social
security or anything from what's the
matter with me
so i wonder if that is required because
if you're also immunocompromised that
should be taken into account as well
because i probably won't get it because
i am
yeah so look the ada adata.org says
the americans with disabilities act
became law in 1990. the ada is a civil
rights law that prohibits discrimination
against individuals with disabilities in
all areas of public life including jobs
school transportation public and private
places
that are open to general public the
purpose of the law is to make sure that
people with disabilities have the same
rights and opportunities as everyone
else
the ada gives civil rights protections
to individuals with disabilities similar
to those
provided to individuals on the basis of
race color sex national origin age
religion
it guarantees equal opportunity for
individuals with disabilities in public
accommodation employment transportation
state local government services
and telecommunications so i wonder if
they would argue
that you know okay so actually it says
in 2008 the ada was signed into law
and became effective on january 2009 the
a
i'm sorry yes so so the the it's the
americans of disability amendments act
it made a number of significant changes
to the definition of disability
the changes in the definition of
disability apply to all titles of the
ada
so i have to go through the all the
changes but i'm curious if
your doctor says i'm sorry because of
your condition
you are not able to get this vaccine she
said i wouldn't recommend it
you got to take your doctor's advice i
know yeah so for everybody listening if
your doctor says you should listen to
your doctor back says you should
listen to your doctor because i think
you know you don't want to be getting
advice from people on the internet
according to that what you just read it
didn't say anywhere in there that
um like a restaurant can refuse cannot
refuse service to someone because of a
disability it sounds like that law
doesn't protect it it does
public accommodation means restaurants
but it's a private accommodation public
accommodation means
like a service provided to the general
public so a restaurant is a public
accommodation
because it's a store because it's open
to the public interesting so
basically a private shop would be like
members only you can't come in
public is a sign saying open so if
you're
you know so so if somebody walks into
your restaurant you can't accuse them of
trespassing
unless you warn them first if you have a
private if you have a closed
private membership only restaurant and
someone walks in it's trespassing
typically you still got to warn people
it's trespassing no matter what
but the general idea is if it says open
you're allowing people in
it's a public accommodation but i mean
actually it's more nuanced than that
even a private membership business can
still be considered a public
accommodation
like if someone says i would like to
join and become a member and you say you
can't because your disability then they
can sue you and say you're denying them
a public accommodation
could it be like uh this is a covid
vaccine-only
restaurant that's what i'm wondering i
really don't know
it depends on the definition of
disability so
i would i would imagine that means some
kind of medical condition and if you
have a medical condition that prevents
you from getting the vaccine
this is why we want herd immunity
because some people can't get it
right like there was this viral this
viral uh tweet from this woman
she's taking a picture of herself
getting the vaccine she's 14 weeks
pregnant have you seen this yeah i don't
know if it's real so again take it
take it all the grain of salt and i i
absolutely want to make sure i preface
a lot of these stories you know don't
take one story as evidence of widespread
anything anecdote yeah talk to your
doctor i do personally know a pregnant
woman who has
gotten the vaccine and she's fine i i
haven't heard anything yes there you go
she's fine
and this in this viral meme a pregnant
woman gets a vaccine and then a few days
later has a miscarriage
and it could happen it could be right
honestly miscarriages
when they happen they usually were going
to happen anyway yeah
14 weeks though you're out of the first
trimester which is when
90 happen and then so i mean it could
have just been a coincidence it could
have been related to the vaccine we
don't know that
it could have just been all ready to
happen well
there there were in in i think the uk
doctors said
if you are a pregnant woman wait if you
have food allergies
wait yep talk to your doctor first and
so right right then it's like what are
we going to do are we going to deny
someone access to
the buy milk and bread because your
doctor says no
i think i don't know that's a civil
rights violation yeah i think so too
human rights imagine if they were like
you have to weigh a certain amount to
come into the store
because we know that obesity is a
contributing like causes large
large amounts of death every year so you
go to walmart and they're like oh
you're too heavy to come into this store
or if someone has the flu
like 70 or 80 percent of kovid deaths
were obese
yeah yeah large number that's alarming
we're obese i mean and that's why
i think america is having such an issue
with this because we're so
fat we're fat guys i think so there's a
lot of
a lot of excess that's sad and such an
important part of this puzzle
if you look at like the mediterranean
they're not anywhere and people are like
well that's because they're social
distancing and wearing massively no
that's because they're not fat
i saw a meme where it was like two two
lines going to two different kiosks and
one line was like
shots and pills and the line was
saturated all these people were in there
was
changing lifestyle yeah yeah i saw that
can we talk about fats on here
yeah this is interesting disability is
defined according to this website as a
physical or mental impairment
that substantially limits one or more
major life activities
a record of such impairment or being
regarded as having such an impairment
that's interesting because the vaccine
passport is what would make it a
disability
if right now your actor's like here's
our advice to you
and for your you know you weren't
advised because of your blood condition
you shouldn't get it
so that's not a disability but if they
then say everyone all these businesses
have to have vaccine passports all of a
sudden now it is it's restricting you
from a major
you know major access to you know
services and stuff like that
interesting yeah and then you'd be able
to get disability insurance because you
couldn't go to the store
i wonder how would that work you gotta
hire someone to do it for you yeah i
don't know i mean i don't
my blood condition i i don't create red
blood cells
so that's why i'm so pale and why i get
winded going up the stairs
but that's um that's that's mine and i
mean you can't really see it you can't
really tell
um i don't want to you know carry a
passport around with it that
tells you know the stranger at the
supermarket what's the matter with me i
mean yeah
so this is the issue i take with the
libertarian party because
the government isn't going to be the one
starting the vaccine passports
they're they're oh no we can't do it and
they can't 14th amendment great
all these laws sure but a private
company can and then what happens
oh thank heavens it's not the government
it's just it's just walmart and amazon
amazon you want to buy something online
it's like before a delivery driver can
come to your house you must prove you're
vaccinated
otherwise you're putting our drivers at
risk it's like well uh what am i
supposed to scan your qr code enter your
vaccine number
and then that's what private companies
will do yeah well that's um
that's a different so i was talking
earlier about libertarianism how
it's a spectrum from anarchy to
constitutionalism
it's just a matter of how much
government is necessary and how much
government
is needed so um
so an anarchist view would just be like
nope we're just
you know they can do whatever they want
until the cows come home and there's
nothing we can do and you know
it's like oh for instance it's like
with what's going on social media oh
they're like create another
we're at a point where you need to
create another internet at this point
like you can't create
more um more social media because they
do that like parlor did that and what
happened
gone yeah you know so so we're at a
point where it's like well why didn't
you just create another internet and so
it's like okay maybe elon musk will get
on that i don't know but um
trump yeah trump trump could get on that
i mean there are
they could happen but you're going to be
bound to those rules too so
it's just a matter of like i like i said
i'm a menarcus so i believe in
justice and defense that's that's really
the limits of what i believe
um to be the government's
um role for enforcing the constitution
um and so i would have to think at it
from that
perspective okay so are people like
where's justice
gonna like are people gonna be is there
gonna be an injustice here
like if people are not being served
if people can't is there an injustice
should the government
interfere because of this this human
rights injustice essentially if you
can't
have you know buy food or if you can't
like this is where it gets a little
sketchy this is why i think the
libertarian party is pro-authoritarian
yes they are
they're like the pawns of authoritarian
corporatist monopolist power
yes there you have massive multinational
corporations and they're going oh no the
government is being mean to our
overlords
it's like what if you're actually for
libertarian views the little l like true
opposition to authoritarianism it
doesn't matter if it's a corporation or
government
they're both organizations just in
different capacities the government is
organized there's an organized group of
people who do a thing
a corporation is the same they have
structures they have a hierarchy they
have control
some companies are co-op some are
non-profits some governments are
democracy some are autocratic some are
i mean you had that guy what was that
name in what was that guy's name in
uruguay
uh jose mohica was that his name i'm not
sure he was like the president he lived
on a little farm he had a little car and
everyone loved him
i remember him yeah yeah so you have
some governments like that
government is not the same thing
everywhere
and corporations aren't the same thing
everywhere both can monopolize power and
cause problems
i happen to lean against you know i i
the reason communism and socialism are
bad
is because it's a bunch of people
sitting down going i have an idea let's
centralize all the power with one group
of people
it's like that's a that's a really bad
idea and then the problem i see with
ancaps and the libertarian party is
they're like
we should allow major corporations to
slowly accrue power so that a small
handful of individual elites control
everything and i'm like
what's the difference if your life is
dictated to
to you by someone else so we need to
restrict corporate power
and government power but you know we
don't we don't we don't get the left
his typically being like the
corporations are bad and the right being
like government is bad i'm like hey hey
hey hey
they're both bad both you guys are just
both awful yeah yeah
they're both yeah well they both are
just awful well if you look at
what what these corporations are like we
could have thousands and thousands of
competitors like you know we could have
like everybody everybody out there
competing against each other and what
was i saying that there are what there's
there's like 10
10 businesses 10 corporations that just
own everything
they just own everything and what are
some perks that they have they have
um they they get billions in subsidies
billions
they they get special protections by the
government
um and then you know they buy up their
competition
and so there's language in the 14th
amendment
for government granted monopolies which
if you're given the money and you're
given the protections you're probably
granting their ability to exist
yes so if there's language against that
that
those should not exist and that's it's
just not being enforced because too many
of these
politicians are dirty and they're
profiting off these corporations they're
in bed with the corporations
so why are they gonna why were they
gonna they're gonna get a job once they
once they get out of office yeah
it's a hard job man you're fundraising
non-stop lobbyism
lobbyists maybe you don't get paid that
much money but then afterwards you get
this permanent access pass to capitol
hill
and all of a sudden now you can do
lobbying yep they can lobby these
government granted
monopolies they're supposedly du jour
monopolies meaning by law
they'd be the government is like
instilling and but these
these aren't dujour monopolies these
aren't like twitter it's not a
government grant a monopoly even though
the government
subsidizes to be honest i don't know
what what they subsidize with twitter
but it's a de facto monopoly they are by
fact it's not by law they're not legally
monopolized they just have monopolized
the social sphere if the government
admits that they're
what'd you say du jour yeah monopoly
then they have to abolish them
exactly so a lot of there's going to
exist de facto i hear a lot from
the lazer fair capitalist or ancap types
and they'll say things like
tim you're not talking about a real
capitalism real capitalism you're
talking about corporatism and the
government's interference which creates
these monopoly monopolies
it's only because of special access and
special rules that the government
holds back the competition and props up
these big companies
and that's kind of true with section 230
for instance empowers those that are
massive to get away with whatever they
want and then destroy their opponents
but i'm like the idea that this isn't
real capitalism just sounds
like utopian to me it's not real
communism sure that's not real
capitalism i'm like listen
capitalism is infinitely better than
communism in a million different ways
unfettered capitalist capitalism
outright will eventually
see power coalesce around a small
handful of people with or without
government regulation
we need to stifle that concentration of
power
i don't necessarily know how taxes is
one way yeah
yeah the problem is it just powers the
government then you know what i mean and
the government just then grows and
becomes massive
and then they effectively just create a
revolving door between the massive
multinational corporations
themselves i mean you gotta elect people
who are gonna
be like all right you're a monopoly we
need to call you that we need to get rid
of you
and also they're all puppets the
government's centralized too which is a
problem
exactly it's a monopoly the government
is a monopoly it's a monopoly on
violence and the ability to take money
from people we didn't have the
technology a bunch of bunch of
millionaires
imagine if netflix had a group of like
people with guns that they would show up
at your house and be like you have to
give you have to sign up for netflix and
you're like i don't want to too bad
yep that's right we're yeah so if the
government made a social media
site and then they were like you have to
sign up well you're automatically signed
up in the social security in the uk you
have the tv licensing fee or whatever
everyone has to pay it unless you don't
have a computer
or a tv and it funds the bbc i guess
we're in a weird place where centralized
government
it still kind of works well no i mean it
kind of works but we're building tech
that allows us to decentralize the way
we vote the way we interact with each
other via television and internet video
and things like that no you only think
that bro
well we're on the cusp of like a new way
of like putin and
biden could get on a youtube video chat
tomorrow and have a two-hour live stream
together
sure that's not decentralization though
that's pure centralization he doesn't
putin doesn't have to fly to dc we don't
have to centralize
anymore that's that's semantics bro no
we can communicate one more
right when we're talking about
decentralization we're talking about
distributing power between different
nodes not one
point biden putin arguing is pure
centralization of power
when they're talking to each other
you're talking about spiritually or
psychologically
yeah putting all the power in an
individual yeah but actually
centralizing the fourth
like washington dc used to be the
centralized point of our power structure
no longer we can the government can
function from anywhere and probably does
it does that's why the people storming
the capital it's like what were you
thinking that was so stupid right
we're going to enter this building and
that's it it's like no that's not it
it's the internet exists what are you
doing yeah as those people
so maybe maybe a government i have a
feeling government will be built
that that facilitates the technology
and i don't i suppose it's up to the
people i think
the blockchain stuff is valuable i think
crypto is valuable
but if you think that these technologies
are decentralized i got a bridge to sell
you
you think that the u.s government just
sat back and watched bitcoin grow
exponentially and did not buy large
portions of of the blockchain and set up
servers all over the place
maybe they did maybe they didn't okay
maybe maybe we can say the us
government's inept and that's possible
but i kind of feel like there's probably
confidential
stuff we don't know about we know china
was buying tons of bitcoin i'd be
willing to bet the u.s
tried to buy 51 to whatever network they
could
and they're constantly doing whatever
they can to maintain control of that
network
because if they got 51 then they they
own it
not decentralized sure well
we're not just relying on blockchain
there's other decentralized networks
like uh
interplanetary file system ipfs and new
ones that keep getting built
um and 51 is better than a hundred
percent
well no but what do you mean all they
need in order to control 100 of a
network is 51
of the computers okay that's why i guess
why i said on the cusp we're not at a
point where
we have a decentralized system but you
know that is a light at the end of the
tunnel maybe or a light in the distance
decentralization require like
interstellar colonization
you know what what effectively allowed
us to break away from that from the
british empire was prob was was the
distance
3000 miles away it was very hard for
them to enforce anything yeah
and if we don't have a decentralized
system when we colonize mars it will be
solar war
so we have to for our survival solar war
i don't know if we do not want the first
solar war i don't know if we'll get to
that point
you know colonies on mars or wherever
else they're going to require a stream
of supplies
yeah yeah they're not going to be able
to survive on their own without
resources coming in for some time
maybe in 50 years 200 years we'll have
biodomes and
we'll be taxing them and be like we send
you your supplies not anymore
and they throw all the space tea into
the into the
space space harbor on mars there's so
much they eject it into space yes
all that iron on this all that red dust
is iron oxide yeah yeah there's a lot of
iron on mars
they make martian swords with it send
them back to earth
but then the military's like we don't
sword fight anymore so they don't buy
them and then mars is like what are we
supposed to do and we need food
and so then we buy them anyway as like a
a goodwill gesture to like make it seem
like we actually are buying something
when reality just like
arbitrarily making them work in exchange
for resources they declare independence
and they'll die
oh okay all right you know what story
was written
we are going to talk about some serious
stuff but you know what no we're not
speaking of mars and aliens and whatever
other nonsense we've been talking about
check the story out from the daily mail
former director of the cia james woolsey
says he was skeptical about aliens
until a friend's aircraft was paused at
40
000 feet and he hopes we can be friendly
to the other creatures if they exist let
me say that again
until a friend's aircraft was paused
four thousand feet what does that like
track tractor beam like who's it what
friend is he talking about oh let's read
friends
a friend's aircraft i thought that he
said he saw it he saw a friend's
aircraft get passed
whoa yeah or look i mean he could have
had a stroke
yeah i was just watching star trek
earlier and it was the episode where
time keeps freezing
have you guys seen that one i've seen
them all they're in the they're in the
the run about the shuttle and then all
of a sudden
diana troy is sitting there and everyone
just freezes like stops in time
it's because there's fragments of
space-time continuum moving like
shattering all around them and they're
like a mushroom trip oh my god
so anyway to then hear the story i'm
like that's what happened
that's brilliant crazy check it out he's
uh well as he said
that stories always seemed pretty far
out to me but there was one case in
which a friend of mine was able to have
his aircraft stop
at forty thousand feet or so and not
continue operating as a normal aircraft
what was going on i don't know does
anybody know
walter said the source was someone i
respect john
greenwald jr the host pointed out that
the other former cia directors have said
they are open to the possibility of
alien life
in december john brennan told the
podcast he felt it was arrogant to
believe that we were alone in the
universe
life is defined in many ways brennan
said during the during the december 16th
episode now hold on
this story comes out right another story
came out another story comes at around
the same time what's up with this
nbc news drones that swarmed u.s
warships
are still unidentified navy chief says
the military is expected to deliver a
report later this year to congress on
the unidentified aerial phenomena
this is from april 5th 11 24 pm just
last night
they published this story a bunch of
naval destroyers have tic-tac-shaped
objects
hovering for 90 minutes at high speed
just sitting there
beyond commercial drone technology and
they don't know what it is
so marco rubio talked about it and he
was like whatever is going on with these
things
flying over our military installations
it's like a national security
breach like our security has been
breached and we don't know what it is
is a major threat to this country then
we get this story coming out where this
dude's like oh yeah
my friend's aircraft was frozen at 40
000 feet
what is that all right so i think that
there's
aliens so i i think this could be
could be three different things and i'm
gonna probably forget them as i list
them but
um one i mean there could be some
technology
that china made that got in because
they're targeting the military bases
they're not no normal people are saying
this people in the government are seeing
these people in the military are seeing
this
i'm not seeing it you're not seeing it
you know what if it's okay
it could be aliens that are like all
right we've targeted
the uranium i have no idea so it could
be aliens all right
okay i'll put it out there could be
aliens we could have aliens all right um
it could be that they do know what it is
but aliens are more interesting
yes um so it's gonna distract us from
whatever it is
that is trying to kill us or it could be
that they just put stories like this out
well they're passing draconian
legislation so we're distracted
i don't know i gotta look and see what's
going on in the legislature
yeah it could be that earth is a zoo you
know the great zoo hypothesis
oh yeah you guys know about fermi's
paradox lightly
the general idea is like if the universe
is so vast and massive
and life does exist then shouldn't we
have found some
evidence of intelligent life somewhere
else at some point and so then there's a
bunch of answers people propose like
there's the um the great i think was it
called the great barrier or something
i don't know the the great filter sorry
that all life at a certain point wipes
itself
out for some reason one of them is the
zoo hypothesis that earth is effectively
a zoo
and that we're in a big cage where the
aliens come to watch us and
giggle at the stupid things that humans
do i think south park called it
reality tv that earth was just a reality
tv show for the aliens and they all
watched and laughed at us
and then they canceled us and they're
going to blow the earth up and they got
i remember that
yeah yeah yeah there's another really
creepy really creepy
um idea of what what could
what it could be why we haven't seen
anybody because the more intelligent
beings out there know that there is
something
that there is something bigger and worse
than anything in the universe they know
what it is and they don't want it to
find us
but we're stupid is that darkness yeah
there's there's something out there they
know about they don't want it to find
them but it's like hey let's look for
yep yeah let's look oh and we're sitting
there we're sitting there going like
hello
like you're it's like it's like the
friend who walks like like the friend
walks into the old cabin
like kind of give me chills the first
time i read it i'm like wow we're dumb
[Music]
we're like yelling into the darkness
we're like yelling hello i don't like
the fermi paradox theory that
if life is here then why haven't we
thought shouldn't we have found it
because we just found out ice was on
mars
like six years ago and that there's
likely life within the wat frozen water
and on europa as well
one of them and we also speculate as to
would intelligent life develop emf
technology
and broadcast anything it's it's really
funny that we're like
we just started using radio waves and
now we assume
everybody to be using them i think it's
a waste
kind of a waste of money to a certain
degree like we're building these giant
space telescopes that i understand to
look at stuff but then we also have
seti search extraterrestrial
intelligence where we're looking for
like radio waves and stuff
it's like that's still cool it's
something we should still do and i guess
the hope that we'll find alien life is a
good motivation to do it because we'll
we'll probably discover other things but
this idea that
in the past hundred years or 150 years
we started using radio waves and now
we're assuming other
intelligent life would use the same
technology they could be using like
like light fidelity technology you know
we have that now as well
where are like fiber optics for instance
they could use
a laser that flickers to broadcast data
and we're not going to see that from far
away
you know something that i was hearing
that i don't know too much about this
but
one thing that i heard that they shoot
out into the universe is like math
because math is like universal
i mean unless you live on earth when two
plus two is five
but they try to they they they cast
stuff like that out
one plus one is two you know like things
that make sense
everybody unit is we're in a simulation
oh
there's no other intelligent life
because we're in a simulation
and what we're seeing these tic tac
things
they're they're game man mods you know
they're they're they're game managers
they're they're admins
so it's a it's a nondescript vehicle a
tick tap that can move around seemingly
outside the laws of physics because it's
it's a it's a it's a moderator if you
think about when everything really
went to h e double hockey sticks was
when
they turned on the the atom smasher the
large hadron collider yeah that's it was
2012.
he got forced into the trump dimension
yep yep so and at the same time they
they you know they waved um they
repealed and replaced the propaganda act
at the same time they turned on the
hydran large house
can we make this movie can i can i like
is there a filmmaker out there who wants
to make a
movie about the large hadron collider
fires and it causes a big like ripple
rip ripple yeah space time that blankets
the earth and then all of a sudden it's
like
you see you see hillary clinton walking
up to accept the the the win
on on election night and then all sudden
it just like flickers and then she turns
into trump
and it's like and they're watching in a
protective sphere as reality is being
changed
around them they're like what have we
done i think
yes there is and partly because you just
called for it
so i wonder if alien life is out there
and as soon as we say
alien life come to us it's like i have i
want to go in that direction like
inspiration strikes and here's what i'm
imagining
like all of these world leaders are in
this protective space-time bubble
as they're about to fire the large
hadron collider and then they watch
reality shift around them and like
hillary flickers and then turns into
trump and now trump's the winner
and they're like what have we done and
the world leaders are like
we must fix this and they try to fire up
the large hadron collider again but then
a magnet breaks and they're like oh no
the machine's broken we're trapped in
this dimension
and so then they have to spend four
years accusing trump of being a russian
spy
wall and they're like what have we done
it's broken fix it
and then and then they're like we're
running out of power and then and
they're like
no there was some kind of enhancement in
the reality where trump is president
there was some kind of an animal that
got into that area yeah like a squirrel
yeah a squirrel or a crack or a monkey
some kind of animal that got into the
hadron collider i'm like you know what
i'm like
the squirrel i'm like someone someone
turned themselves into this thing to
stop this from happening and they're
dead now
it's a squirrel and it's chasing it it
finds an acorn the acorn's bouncing down
the hill and it's chasing after it
and then it falls into a vent the
squirrel jumps in and the squirrels in
the large hadron collider and it's
falling right when
right when you get to the middle of it
the the proton goes right through
and mixes with squirrel protons of some
sort it explains so much
and then it causes a ripple anti-matter
explosion
plus squirrel yeah one squirrel but in
all seriousness there was an animal that
did get into the hadron collide
yeah i'm telling you the truth oh my any
idea what kind of animal i can't
remember but somebody can look it up
i remember i remember reading this story
about a dude who was at was in
a uh not the large hadron collider but
he was in a super collider
and something a proton a single point
like went through his head oh my god and
it messed him up in a really weird way
but didn't kill him
it just like screwed with his brain
because it was like my gosh what if
they've done that to like
article they did that to all the dems
yeah everyone just got a single proton
fired through their brain and now
they're all like
everything is woke i heard this um this
incan
scientist explaining the reason the
pyramids are there is because
protons are flying at earth from outer
space because our the earth's magnetic
core is negatively charged because
it's just iron and so the protons fly
through the surface of earth
through our bodies causing free radical
damage and then when they get close to
the center of the earth
the positive energy at the center forces
it to repel and go flying back out and
back through our bodies again
so they built these pyramids to channel
the positive energy on its way back
out and focus it through a point to like
gather it up from the surroundings so it
didn't cause free radical damage on the
humans i got into
these egyptians were so so smart i have
an easier answer to
why there's pyramids all over the place
because people who didn't know that much
it was the easiest thing to build let me
stack
rocks like this there you go you bought
the structure you stacked some rocks
yeah it might have been like
also a tomb also a battery it was capped
with gold which is a superconductor well
if there was it looks like there's water
channels inside of it and if there's a
charge
like if the water was called ancient
aliens there's this thing called the
telerik current
in the earth that's like this low
frequency magnetic current
that flows and apparently it's it's
strong under where the pyramids are
tesla was working to lyric earth current
yeah interesting it's a it's an electric
current that moves through uh
moves underground or through the sea to
lurk currents result from both natural
causes and human activity
and the discrete currents interact in a
complex pattern the currents are
extremely low frequency and travel over
large areas at or near the surface of
the earth
interesting well i don't know wikipedia
says it's true so it must be true tesla
was tapping into it and trying to send
electricity through the ground and
people obviously wanted to sell their
copper wires
so they shut that down but i think this
technology might be have something to do
with that with these drones
or these things that we're seeing flying
around uh they're charged by it
possibly or or it's on board fusion or
it's like a light
or it's like like a light refraction
that we think is a craft
i don't know maybe it's just like
solid-state batteries
yeah that someone developed and we don't
know they could just be someone could
have just
developed it i mean they're watching the
military forces and they're watching you
know north korea and they're they're
watching all the targets but what if
it's just some dude in his basement
i mean you know like that's like lex
luthor level stuff yeah
having these drones that defy modern
technology
like jeff bezos i don't think maybe jeff
i love you and you're not lex luthor
but yeah your shaved head makes you and
and you know what
and i've been thinking about too is mark
zuckerberg he's he's a really cool guy
yeah there's nothing wrong with him cool
mark mark zuckerberg just great jeff
bezos
awesome oh god i love that amazon
wouldn't be
experimenting with drone technology man
i love how it's like very obvious we
don't like them i wouldn't be surprised
if bezos has like a secret lab where
he's doing crazy dude i mean that was
the story
the guy who's doing global shipping
drones helping all these people
also secretly spying on american
military bases
it was funny when i tweeted elon musk i
was like i was like hey elon why haven't
you bought an iron man suit yet and he
tweeted back
building starship and i'm like all right
fair point you know it's like
high point okay you know that's high
point yeah unacceptable he's doing the
shield
thing is that isn't it he's sheldon he's
building a ship to go to mars didn't
shield have like a space in orbit nick
fury's
no then the helicarriers you're thinking
justice league had the batman thing in
space
okay so he's doing justice league first
justice league he's going to mars
i think well so if we follow the dc
timeline then what i think's supposed to
happen is elon musk
will send a crew to mars who will
accidentally uncover
an ancient temple where a bunch of
invasive aliens were frozen by the
martians
who will then be awoken by the astronaut
take over his body or
assume his form come to earth and there
will be a secret invasion and you know
the justice league there's a well-known
theory that
um i mean facts are not endorsements
but there's a well-known theory that
there was some kind of nuclear
war between earth and mars which used to
be colonized because of what
yeah because of what it's established
it's an established theory you can look
it up
so yeah so it's that there was some sort
of um
nuclear war some sort of war between
earth and mars which we used to be like
heavily colonized and that's why mars
looks the way it does when did you read
it when did you hear about this oh when
did i hear about that um
i i think i was in a youtube rabbit hole
at three in the morning
a long time ago no because this is from
newsweek march 22nd
viral mars conspiracy theory video
claims humans lived on mars and
destroyed it
there it is youtube rabbit holes yeah so
you can go ahead and read that that is
that was interesting a video in which a
tick-tock user claims humans once lived
on mars but rendered it uninhabitable in
a nuclear war has gone viral
thanks newsweek it's good news that's
been the praise
the false but entertain the false thanks
for letting me know it's false oh cool
yeah that entertaining theory also
states this war
would have caused a nuclear winter which
is responsible for mars popular red
color
iron what i don't think it has currently
been liked more than 230 000 times and
shared nearly 10 000 times that's not
even that many shares
yeah i know i did nothing i didn't like
it or share it i just read it
i think that it has been watched 979
thousand times
that was from our video with alex jones
has doubled the views on that right
this is not this is someone was bored
they were like
this is the stuff that that comes up
when everybody else is shadow band
i wonder if people used to live on venus
you guys ever think about wait wait i'm
sorry i gotta read this
the theory explained by user crackhead
joe dirt
so you know it's it's it's
verified was put forward in response to
the question what's a conspiracy theory
that absolutely blows your mind
crack crackhead joe dirt states mars
isn't naturally red
want to know what can cause a planet
turn red and change after a couple
million years
if enough nukes were to go off on a
planet the first thing that would happen
is a nuclear winter
nuclear winter is the aftermath of
nuclear blasts causing ash that is so
thick
it blocks out the sun nuclear winters
can last anywhere from 100 years
and a thousand depending on how much ash
in the atmosphere
after all the natural resources are
drained up from the nuclear winter the
planet turns red from dust
my theory is that we've come from mars
after we drained all its natural
resources and destroyed it with nuclear
bombs
that is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard the red color is iron
that you can like that was very weirdly
weirdly worded
venus makes way more sense not mars
for sure because the sun's expanding
slowly so it used to not be so hot on
venus
well no venus is hot because of a
greenhouse effect
they thought there were all these
cometary impacts on venus it turns out
they're like explosives from the inside
like
it cooked so hot that it blew out all
this goo outside of itself
and there's all these like explosive
holes where it's inside let's hold on
you know let me tell you a better
conspiracy theory all right mars makes
no sense because mars is too small
it has no magnetosphere as my
understanding so it can't maintain an
atmosphere
so the solar radiation just rips away
the particles and blasts them off the
planet
so we can't terraform it if we wanted to
it's the oceans that caused the field
unless i guess no it's the iron partly
ocean contributes a lot to it so i guess
what we would need to do is like drill
to the center of mars and then
get like ben affleck and the gang to
launch those nukes in sequential order
like in that movie
let me get in i'll tell you what's
better this is sad okay
look i'm sorry crackhead joe dirt i
appreciate your attempt but let me
let me exclude you for a second humans
started on venus
and venus was earth-like but a runaway
greenhouse
effect from mass consumption and carbon
emissions
resulted in the in global warming which
crate was when the pollution started
creating
acid rain the ocean levels started
rising and then once
the american military american but once
the venetian venusian whatever
venus military of one country realized
what was happening they created the ark
project
where they took the dna samples from as
many animals and species as possible and
put it onto a giant space vessel called
the ark
that would ferry as many people as
possible and many animals and creatures
to earth to get here because venus was
being destroyed so they flee and then
the ark project
comes and the great flood sweeps over
venus
wiping out all civilization from global
warming and then they land on earth
and then what do we see in the fossil
record the pre-pre-cambrian explosion
all of a sudden around the same time the
fossil record just boom tons of
different animals why
because the ark project dropped a bunch
of the critters
and then they started populating and
then all started dying around the same
time so now they appeal to here in the
fossil record
as this great unexplainable elite i
don't actually believe that but come on
let's be real
it's a way better conspiracy theory than
men it might explain octopuses we don't
know
looks like a jungle planet that got
superheated
it really looks like it used to be a
jungle planet we landed a drone there
and it got
i think the russians then it got crushed
and just like melted or something
yeah i was i was watching this video
where they claimed that we could make
floating cities on venus because the
gases are so dense
that we could make like floating
platforms on gas just heated by like the
geothermal
heat from underneath i think it's just a
hot planet wow that's a lot of energy
potential to boil water
yeah well you know where on earth we'd
go to mars but mars can't sustain an
atmosphere as my understanding so
what do we do we just trapped on earth
you all know it's really scary you wanna
know the scariest thing
the universe is expanding right uh-huh
so eventually
on earth once the universe expands to a
certain point
you won't actually be able to see any
stars or planets or galaxies or anything
because they'll be so far away that
light traveling towards us
is just doesn't reach us anymore so
they're going to be potentially
creatures on this earth maybe
in a certain amount of time they're born
into existence and they look up at the
black sky and they see nothing and they
think
there's nothing so are we just getting
prepped for that with all this light
pollution
no look we can look at the stars and we
understand the universe exists because
we can see the light that has reached us
but if the universe expands to if it
keeps expanding
eventually it'll be too far away for us
to even see because the light will never
reach us all they'll have is our records
and the teachers will teach the records
until the records become racist and
they're not
going to teach them it'll it'll be faith
it'll be magic they'll be like we know
it doesn't exist because you can look
out there's nothing there it was a bunch
of
dreams and hallucinations of these
people but here's the thing if you can't
see the stars
you can't conceptualize the concept of
outer space and stars
so you'd have to take it on faith no but
the concept wouldn't exist
what if there was something where like
you know interdimensional elves would
randomly appear and then one
day you know a thousand years ago they
all died off so it would come off it'd
come out like
leprechauns don't exist yeah it would it
would be it would become a myth
right right you know way distant out
there there are these things called
stars and you know eventually would fade
into
and they would make movies about like
stars coming to earth and like
giving people magic powers because they
wouldn't understand what it actually was
yeah i think the universe is rubber
banding so
it's it is accelerating now and it's
getting bigger faster but it will
eventually slow back down and start to
come back together and then pop again
that's called big crunch theory it was
disproven a long long time ago i think
there's a lot of those happening like
popcorning all over
so multiverse they initially we had
solid state theory
solid state theories the universe is and
has always been
then we had eventually big bang the big
bang theory that
the universe is expanding and from that
we had a lot of people theorize
something called the big crunch
that if the energy is being pushed out
at a certain point could it
start coming back in a better way to
explain it is if gravity attracts
wouldn't at a certain point everything
condensed into singularities and then
all starts
moving back towards each other wasn't
stephen hawking that was disproven
wasn't he one of the ones that disproved
he didn't he
he thought everything was shrinking and
he like wrote a whole thesis on it
and then he's like now i'm going to
disprove my own theory and he wrote a
whole thesis on how it's expanding
yeah so uh basically where we're at now
is that the universe is actually
accelerating faster and faster and
faster as if the ball is rolling down
the hill at no point will the ball just
stop and then roll well
if it goes down and then goes back up
and then back down and back up
you might start to see it because
gravity is actually a pressure it's
pushing it's not
being it's not a pulling force it's a
pushing force so it's possible that
things are being expelled into a
universe that's actually trying to push
them back but they're still in a rate of
acceleration
and will eventually be pushed back
together so i guess it is still a
hypothesis
when you look it up they just basically
say it's a hypothesis
that's good there's something called the
big bounce settled propose that it keeps
going back and forth a big bang big
crunch big bang bang
that's interesting big bounces yeah big
bounce
um hey regarding what we were talking
about earlier i think the cia is giving
us this information i think that's just
rampant what the cia does you think that
they're giving it just to distract us
and keep us
like talking about aliens while they do
their dirty work yes and some of them
maybe are truly deluded and making crazy
theories or they did hear from a friend
something um i don't trust like hidden
sources well i know one of the sources
that i
red flagged me was the john brennan
yes yeah what happened in the article it
said john brennan says that we're stupid
to sing or arrogant to think that we're
the only species
as soon as they quoted john brennan i'm
like john brennan is just dirty swampy i
love john brennan
me too yeah yeah you know i would love
to you know be like the best evening
ever
what bezos zuckerberg brennan you know
just
hanging barack obama company yeah yeah
just all these these
these these heroes that'd be awesome
bill gates in a sauna
so it's hot yeah you know actually
actually you know be really great what
in a sauna with brennan bill gates
zuckerberg bezos and alex jones
oh oh that might actually be fun
yeah you have to wear like a shield
though because you'd go off i'd
pay for that i'd like to be in this
sauna at this time well
whatever this conversation is begins
mm-hmm
cold water i'd watch it on pay-per-view
yes
pay-per-view yeah yeah put a gopro in
there all right how about we go to super
chats everybody
my friends if you're listening right now
and you really want to help out the show
give us a like because your comments
your likes your engagement
you're basically telling youtube the
show is good so when you do that it
really does help us out don't forget to
subscribe
hit the notification bell because
subscriptions often don't matter all
that much notifications do
and just share the show with your
friends if you think it's good because
that ultimately is what really helps us
grow
and go to temcast.com become a member
because we'll have a bonus segment
coming up
after the show for members only let's
read some of these super chats we got
rom shell says ian crossland i used to
watch your youtube videos when i was in
high school
people don't realize how much of a
legend you are thank you ramchill
i got a comment the other night they're
like i remember this video came out when
i was six
oh wow and now i'm 21.
time is weird time is weird
[Laughter]
time is time is weird when they're
growing up
swinging panda says my province is going
back into phase one lockdowns our
premiere is a total tool alberta is a
joke appreciate your freedoms america
well when you're out in the middle of
nowhere i can walk around whatever i
want
we have chickens we were just sitting
there watching them do chicken stuff
bigger yeah the chickens are at the age
where they're jumping on top of their
houses
a couple of them are mm-hmm and it's
like wait what are you doing what are
you doing chicken
yeah so for a long time they were really
scared now a couple of the big ones
like i'll put my hand near them and
they'll just look at me and like peck my
face awesome
yes yeah because they're like today yeah
like i know this guy i'm glad you've
been there for them i was not really
around for their childhood
the chickens yeah two weeks
they don't know you they grow up so fast
they'll remember me
all right lester leo says trump promised
to build 1 000 miles of wall in eight
years
450 miles of walls were built before he
left the uh left house
he was on schedule yeah so that was on
schedule right right on schedule
yep he fulfilled a promise i guess i
mean he did that in four years
yep he was as bad as they made him out
no god knows oh my god jose pereira says
it's not a wall it's a la it's a tall
large tall structure that separates
boundaries
okay thank you a narrow yes influx
more clarification not
a serial killer says supporters since
the beginning been following tim since
wall street
please shout out my man brent's comic
take the monkey and run on kickstarter
oh there you go take the monkey and run
on kickstarter
all right the lukewarm gamer says do you
think the fall of comics as the
go woke has as they go woke has anything
to do with anime and manga are getting
more popular in the west
as they are not woke probably
i definitely think so what do i want to
watch woke captain america
complaining about bigotry or like some
dude who's a pirate and like can punch
dudes from really far away and another
guy who's like a swords guy with a sword
in his mouth and he's like cutting
people with it
attack on titan's pretty weird too i
don't know like people turn to giant
monsters or something my daughter got me
uh watching this anime uh uh something
neverland somebody knows what it's
called
the something never lands someone will
say it um it's it's about these these
orphans who all live with this
you know woman and she's she's sending
them out to be adopted and they love her
they call her mom
and apparently she's sending them to
monsters to be eaten or
to be in oh yeah so when they find out
and they find out about it so now they
have to escape but i'm like
the promise neverland the promise
neverland isn't that infinitely more
interesting than captain america being
way more interesting you are racist yeah
yeah
you're right see i'd rather watch that
with my daughter then did you guys ever
see stan lee's
superhumans no he
and look for people with real like one
guy could like magnetically stick
pans to his head one guy could like put
bison to sleep with his energy
he had this like contortionist guy was
the host i mean that's stan lee he
he got tired of the the bull of the crap
and was like i'm finding real super
human people
which of which there are special he's
cool that's a big
people that could like get super hot and
like cause steam off their wet shirts
and stuff
yeah we got the political commentator
says shout out to josie she's awesome
and i for one am proud that she isn't
party approved
much of the libertarian party now is a
joke unfortunately
if you're a real libertarian she's the
one you got to follow that's true
who said that the political commentator
the political commentator
yes we follow each other there you go oh
thank you
aaron says this is for ian i know you're
not crazy about having kids but if you
asexually reproduce you should name your
son lil ian and your daughter lillian
that's clever yeah i think i did see ian
the other day budding
yeah he was yeah he's kind of butting up
i'm into it it's just coming and then it
fell off his arm
and then eventually grew legs and ran
off i think that we are fungus that ate
animal that ate other fungus
like what happened was in the tide pool
there was all this plant matter and then
there were all this fungus and some of
the fungus ate plant matter and stayed
fungus some of the fungus ate other
fungus and became animal
oh why do you think that because i'm
crazy
i'm just using logic all right i'll
accept that explanation too much fungus
all right so super for education says
alpha and beta particles are also
ionizing radiation not just gamma rays
okay right all right let's see
bobby lane says tim please look into the
epa's plan to
band modified cars even if for use on
race tracks
if there are any car enthusiasts police
sign the rpm act that
semma is putting together interesting
all right
well let's see what is this gerg c says
tim congratulations of being around such
beautiful people
please be careful when purchasing land
in the future make sure the land you
purchase includes the mineral
rights oh i know all about that oh yeah
yeah a lot of land in rural areas
they've already sold the mineral rights
and they try to sell you surface rights
and all sudden one day some guy shows up
with a bulldozer and he's like i got the
contract ion what's underneath
yeah and then there's like restrictions
on like you have to allow them certain
access and oh
so no all right let's see
realm explorer says star trek deep space
nine season three episode 11
and 12 past tense crazy how close this
two-part episode is to reality now
and in the near future realm explore
haunted abandoned and exploration videos
that sounds fun i definitely want to
fund that too so some urban explorers
going around to old demand and stuff
i think one of the things we want to do
is we talked about doing the paranormal
podcast
but i think i i want to get someone to
go and explore the the monsters of west
virginia
because there's a bunch there's like
mothman like sasquatch yeah
yeah i remember the mothman yeah i was
watching the show on travel channel the
other day it was like
the scariest places in the u.s or
something and they did this really funny
thing where they would interview someone
in broad daylight and it was really not
scary at all
but they would hold the camera at an
angle pointed upwards
and then do something called feathering
where it makes the rim around them look
dark
and then they would just drop the
brightness so it looks dark out and the
camera is at an angle and point it up
and then they'll put eerie music and i'm
like silly
it works there's like a guy standing
before he's like uh my dog went outside
and like
he got eaten by something and then it's
like the cameras and angles going
and i'm like this is crazy man there's
this dude named bradley garrett
you can follow him on twitter at goblin
merchant he uh he's been on rogan before
and he's an urban explorer oh
he has written books about it he would
go under london like deep under london
there's different layers there's like oh
yeah they got like a
throne of skulls or something like they
have catacombs all over the place yeah
did you want to hear crazy stories yeah
so i i i've been to the catacombs in
france
because they have like a tour you go
down and you go into this one approved
area and there's just like
dead people skulls and bones all over
the place but you can actually go down
deeper
i think what happened was in italy they
needed a place to like get rid of bodies
so they built catacombs right
there was a party some college kids were
having and they went down into like
a very like not far
in part of the catacombs right there
like in the beginning i guess you could
call it
and some girl went to go take a leak and
so she went around the corner took a
leak
and then forgot how she got there took a
wrong turn they found her weeks later
starved to death
dehydrated just dead in the catacombs
because miles she got lost
oh my god don't be dumb oh my gosh what
a nightmare
catacombs has there been could you
imagine what a place to die
oh being lost in this game
it takes over in the darkness you're
just and they're just surrounded by dead
bodies oh my gosh no reception
why would you do that that's crazy
she was drunk she was drunk and she took
the wrong turn and then
one wrong turn and you're gone and they
were like she's gone two weeks later
they went and found her and she was just
out of dehydration i guess just like
yeah
anyway yeah horrifically awesome
james harrelson says the portland fire
bomber who was just indicted for last
summer's terror rights
he's from indiana and his name is malik
muhammad maybe nation of islam
just like the capitol hill barricade guy
who also was from indiana
i got my tin foil on tim well speaking
of tin foil
if you haven't smashed the like button
one thing you can do is go to
timcast.com and click shop
because we have the limited edition
tinfoil gorilla available
that it's very much the same as the
regular i am a gorilla shirt but he's
wearing a tin foil hat
and the iron or grill is written in
black letters instead of white letters
i think this one will only be up for a
little while and will eventually
eventually take it down because it was
just a special edition
same thing is true for the for the
diamond hands gorilla which is we got
that one right there
right here yeah that's where he's the
wall street guy he's got a cigar and
he's holding
you know stacks of cash this one's a
misprint yeah it's a little too dark
yeah this was misprinted it's a little a
little too dark but uh it's it's okay
he's got the cigar i like he's looks so
happy yes he's got his diamond hands
gorilla man that guy is a character
waiting
to be fleshed out yeah we should make a
show yeah about he's a gorilla who goes
around telling people to enjoy life
guerrilla tactics
he's gonna he's gonna be a psychic
gorilla who tells people how to improve
their lives and offers them self-help
and tells them to be responsible for
themselves you can like smash stuff
like a superhero yeah yeah yeah i'd
already read this before i'd read the
red skull
and he meets parody versions of captain
america and explains to him that he's
you know got to allow people to explore
ideas and be free and
that everyone he doesn't like is not a
racist right exactly he lived in a cage
until he was like 16 and someone let him
out of his cage and
so ever since he wants to give back he
lived he lived in a cage
but what happened was he gained his uber
powers because while he was in the cage
in the dark he began meditating and
through the power of meditation
he gained enlightenment and then started
levitating in his cage and when they
found him
the cage had already dematerialized and
he floated out to the sun he developed
connection to alien races through the
meditation interdimensional other
characters
through the dmt now we have a universe
yes
wait that's a better idea let's make a
superhero comic about a gorilla who took
dmt
he didn't know where he was getting it
but it's the case he was eating acacia
plants
a regular gorilla walking around and
it's just like really boring looking and
then he just like stumbles over and sits
down and eats
a gorilla is minding his own business
meanwhile a podcast host
is on a trip in africa and drops dmt
not realizing it the gorilla finds it
and takes it and then his mind just goes
and then he gains access to the
interdimensional network and the elves
endow him with super intelligence and
psychic powers
well no there's a problem with this
what's that what's that because that's
the start of curious george and it was
deemed racist because the white man
the yellow hat the man in the yellow hat
okay
ted wait the ted gave curious george dmt
no ted gave him
purpose yeah so
uh so so this is offensive now vr
goggles have you ever seen the video of
the
the monkey with the vr goggles i haven't
some people say it's animal abuse but
the monkey's like going crazy
kind of a cool
[Laughter]
he was trying to climb the walls or
something
all right vegas girl says tim you should
have donald trump on
as a guest yes the problem is trump
would would instantly get his banned
because they literally banned trump
he's a voice disguiser yeah yeah and
we'll
it'll clearly be trump when he's like
we'll pixelate his face
and he's talking like this look i'll
tell you what happened to this election
okay
the radical left behind the radical lift
like we know who that is right facebook
is like can can we ban them
what if what if we put on facebook it
was clearly not trump but we claimed it
was would they ban us
that'd be fun like if it was just a
silhouette of a guy who looks like trump
doing the same yeah the algorithms would
ban you have you seen
the trump playing the accordion videos
yes
they're the best thing in the world
amazing
i love it it's so much boring now with
biden i guess we can make fun of his
speech impediments
oh that's sad they have i mean
snl is trash but they have some i love
snl
but clarify yeah i love them but they
have um
you know some some impersonators on
there but they're always trying to give
it like a cute spin to how
nice he is you know like instead of like
calling out the
the political david carvey actually did
a good impression of him
yeah yeah it wasn't it was just on an
interview it wasn't
you know the worst was alec baldwin it's
like he wasn't even trump i don't
understand what he was impersonating
it was impersonating the idea right
right right so people would actually
watch trump it was the caricature
that they were in person remember that
trump movie that came out like eight
months ago
it got all this attention for like a
week and then just disappeared trump
yeah it was a movie about trump and like
some famous guy portrayed trump
um oh yeah yeah yeah it made him look
all vile
it was like soft core adult stuff yes
what like yeah
okay so it was like we should watch that
revenge fantasies
are we we gotta read some more super
chats we got bobby bob says we were told
the patriot act was for our own good and
safety and is needed
sure look at what it got us and in the
middle east they say the same thing
about covet passports
dude i'm not i'm not down for patriot
act bs and stuff yeah
it's called patriot though adam collins
says
tim i live in maryland and i just
renewed my license to get the real id i
had to use my voter ideas identification
i just thought you would like to know
huh
it's double racist huh punk rock fox as
i live in dearborn michigan best food
the east side is lebanese while the
south is yemeni there are cultural
issues between the two arab groups
lebanese assimilate while the many do
not
interesting that's yeah thank you for
clarifying that yeah
brian schink says shout out to my
podcast shooting the dirt
is it a gun podcast don't do that
zachary kale says it's very important
you understand something
i have extensive experience with
fentanyl what you need to understand is
how you take f when you bite on the
street it's
it's so easy to od i'll tweet to ian
this the specifics
love you redheaded libertarian oh i love
you
the gaelic bat says tim i'm surprised
you didn't mention april 5th as first
contact day i thought you were a trekkie
disc a big fan of the show also free the
code
i said it was trump day and so here's
what i did i tweeted today is 4
5 which will 45 will forever be known as
trump day in honor of the 45th president
it got like 2 300 retweets everyone's
laughing and bunch of lefties are like
no
the next day then today i tweeted today
is 4 6
which will be forever known as biden day
in honor of the 46th president
tomorrow is commonly known no i was like
no some people got it and they were like
that was an excellent
setup because i quoted the other day
like there was a thing i was doing
because you know kamala day is tomorrow
so for
seven they're saying in in star trek
lore four five is the day that zephan
cockrums
uh warp drive caused the vulcans to to
notice earth and come here
oh yeah after a nuclear war and then
authoritarianism and then
the police were being were uh given
drugs
star trek lore is crazy man police were
given drugs for what yeah so there was
like a period
in star trek history where on earth you
know everything was very authoritarian
and the cops would have these drug
things they were just like
oh like super soldier type i think it
was more like narcotics
yeah it could be wrong but there's an
episode in the next generation where q
is wearing this like police riot uniform
with drugs on it talking about the
pathetic history of earth or whatever
oh yeah tng is amazing man yeah really
that's why i haven't got into a deep
space nine because it was so good i
don't wanna i mean dj's nine is good
really
yeah dude design is great come on mm-hmm
voyager's okay you know i saw the first
one
enterprise because i like scott bakula
so much i thought janeway was a good
captain i guess a lot of people didn't
like her
yeah but you know the next generation is
the best so yeah
can't argue with it one patriot says
jordan peterson is a hero
he saved more lives than blm ever will
he inspires millions to face their
shadows become their best self
which terrifies leftists because they
want people to stay in the victim
mindset
dude for real i was in such a dark place
in 2016. i said jordan peterson is a
threat because of
what he speaks he's great chris de luca
says legit the best would have ever had
was that it was
had was a taco truck run by women who
spoke no english
i spoke no spanish google translate for
the win best food ever yeah
nice yeah man i mean you grew up in
certain places
and you'll you'll pick up bits of
different languages i mean especially in
any major city
in new york you're probably going to
learn some spanish and
there's tons of people speak different
languages you'll probably pick stuff up
that's a great american mountain pop man
julie simone says i support legal
immigration and agree with ian
people should be able to speak the
language especially working in public
service
taxpayers shouldn't have to struggle to
communicate with the person at the post
office
in california shaking my head good point
all right let's see we got too many
super chats we have so many
joseph henson says the fact that anne
mccaffrey gets ignored says
it all for these movie companies writers
have been getting worse since the strike
everyone forgot about because some
people did something
interesting yeah i don't know who's that
i'm not sure
i do remember the strike though what is
it uh the writers all went on a strike
yeah and it killed a bunch of shows
because it made them all crazy yeah oh
yeah i think lost was happening in that
time so there was like one season of
loss it might be season four that's just
trash
it doesn't make any sense yep yeah i
remember that
all right let's see
brandon gilmours has been listening for
a little over a year now love the
channel
can i get a shout out for my band under
the gallows we just released a new song
a few new songs oh excellent good job
great josh says i am a gorilla glad to
hear it josh
jalapeno ketchup says so awesome to see
josie on but i hope
figaro is getting his dinner on time
tonight
who is it who's vigorous figaro is my
tuxedo cat he's a norwegian forest cat
so he's big and he's fluffy and he's
friendly and he's more popular than i am
oh wow i like those cats there's those
long hair yep i love this long hair big
yup he's amazing yeah so cute will
beasley says luke went out for a pack of
cigarettes and never came back so
yeah i was sitting here and he was like
i'm gonna run up to the gas station get
some serious you need anything
and i was like just to host for the show
i was like yeah just
just a co-host he was like all right
i'll see you in a few minutes and that
was it he was gone
so betrayed yeah i'll never recover he's
just a co-host
luke actually did he came out to hang
out he wasn't playing on coming on the
show yeah he was gonna be for like three
days
yeah yeah he's like i'll just come hang
out on the way and then
what happened someone canceled i guess
and i was like hey luke we had a
cancellation you want to come on the
show and he was like
i don't know like being tied down no
just it was for one night and he was
like i don't know if i want to do it
and then i was like it's one night dude
we'll do this she's like all right cool
and then we did the show
and then i was like well you're you're
still here you want to just come on
again
and then all of a sudden he was on every
single show for like two months the
audience
awesome absolutely yeah it looks good
dude most people love luke oh yeah
let's see 80 88 games says tim you've
basically explained the plot of gundam
wing with space colony war oh there you
go
oh this is interesting ryan berkabile
says tap one land create one one
squirtle token
pretty powerful land i love it that's a
very powerful candelabra of town as much
what that one yeah but you can only use
it one time yeah it is you could
probably break that though
make a bunch of squirrels what could you
use to repeatedly untap
well you got your your uh in still
energy i'm old school
you got anything could sacrifice a
creature to untap a land adam's deck
basically
probably tap on limited lands because
then you could just infinitely untap a
land
card we talk about magic the gathering
sb says tim check out the ds9 episode
tribunal
o'brien experiences the cardassian
justice system propaganda and
predetermined verdicts very topical now
yeah dude excellent show nova zero says
wrong
51 attack is crap government buying into
only strengthens crypto
get a sme there is the tech the
infrastructure in the market don't
recklessly lump them together
andreas antonopoulos is my
recommendation
he's a bitcoin he's a big-time bitcoin
guy all right well there you go
andrea rojas says hi tim and team will
you guys ever go on tour have a live
show with audience i think it would be
awesome thank you for all you guys do
we have a good question a 40-foot fifth
wheel trailer because
luke convinced us to get one uh and the
idea is that we can actually have this
studio set up
in an rv the plan is to drive out one
weekend to like nashville
do shows there all week and then friday
night do a live show at a venue
then drive to austin same thing then
back to nashville then back home
probably other that's the first idea we
have there's just so much
insane stuff happening in so many
meetings that's very very difficult to
actually do anything and i
like i've got a lot of time so i'm
actually
we have like three big projects for one
the creative enterprise that is gonna be
timcast.com so i am talking with some
people about producing a pilot for a
show and then maybe having an exclusive
comedy show
like full tv show legit on timcast.com
then we're also going to be hiring news
editors writers and i i said i was going
to be doing this fact-checking thing
where we write news organizations and
that's a project and the third most
important thing is
the fetiverse open source subscription
service plugin for people's websites
yeah that's to me like a huge priority i
yeah i heard that the center browser
type
way of going is not necessarily the best
sometimes i sometimes hear from one
person but apparently that's that's
that's dangerous because i'm saying
puts a lot of stress on the on the
company an app
open source free for everybody that you
you put on your website and it creates a
subscription service
whether we're involved or not it's going
to happen so let's do it i want to do it
the idea is then you don't need patreon
you don't need any of these services
you'll just need your financial service
provider if you're running a business
maybe go to a bank get a merchant
account if you're
or you use one of these existing
financial services online and then
all you do is plug in and people can
sign up and then on the first of every
month
whoever is using this open source stuff
you'll see your charge go to all your
favorite creators on their website so
you're a member of their sites instead
of being a member to like disney or
whatever
so then you're getting a big you know a
big
plethora of uh you're getting a plethora
of content we work with minds when we
were building our sorting mechanism we
you basically you'd be subscribed to who
you're subscribed to or you can see
everyone
uh at some point but then you can filter
out words in addition to the things you
want to see like
what's trending hashtag this you can
pick specific words that you want to not
ever show up in your feed so we could do
something like that too for search
algorithms
i mean the idea i guess is not only can
you have your own subscription service
that no one can ban you from people can
donate monthly to your website to get
access to your content so your own
private patreon i guess
but it also networks all the other
websites so if you look at discover
you'll see ian's website you'll see my
website you'll see josie's website
and so it creates the social networking
aspect just through each individual
website and then
we create a directory website you know a
node
showing all the different websites like
a torrent site
and basically you go there and you can
see people posting things and you can
follow certain channels but we don't
host any of it
just an api redirect so then no one can
bend so they could come and be like
you're hosting this guy's kind of
we're not hosting it it's just showing
you a directory of existing content like
itunes does
with podcasts that's smart that's the
plan but it requires some
know-how for the individual has to buy
their own server space have their own
domain and all that stuff
all right tom's pants says soviet
scientist anatoly
bogorski is the guy who took an
accelerated proton to the gourd his
story is really sad even though he lived
yeah didn't like make him go crazy like
it just messed his brain up
in a crazy way um yeah an accelerated
proton to the gore yeah that would be
extreme brain damage
just some happen i'll have to read more
about it yeah definitely
let's see kolo blyson says the fermi
paradox says we've not
found other life because we've studied
less than zero point and a bunch of
zeros one percent of the universe
there you go chris says there is also
accounts in the sumerian text that sodom
was the result of nukes the ancient
texts have an eerie sci-fi feel to it
yeah what was that story where it's like
you know i think it was like god said
don't look back or you'll turn to a
pillar of science
oh yeah yeah so the ancient aliens
people are like it's a nuclear weapon
and they're telling you to run because
if you stop and turn back and watch
you'll get vaporized
that the translation over generation for
generation
it's you'll be turned to ash you'll be
you'll be you'll be disintegrated turns
into
a pillar of salt oh are we sodom and
gomorrah next to each other
were they near each other i think they
were close by yeah i heard that gamora
was on top of a salt mine
um what's what's that gas that it's
produced carbon monoxide
yeah yeah no it's flammable whatever it
is methane maybe methane caused the
giant explosion that destroyed the city
interesting and they thought it was god
strengthened that
and then somebody was like yo that dude
was doing that other dude and that lady
was doing that
those dudes too and so like then it blew
up i don't know man but it sounds to me
like i was like people were probably
like don't do that or god's gonna strike
you down
don't and then the place blew up yeah i
mean it's a lot of like
you know humans didn't understand what's
happening so they correlated what they
could
maybe yeah like some they watched like
some old guy who got bit by like a
crab bit his butt like or snapped his
butt and so he's like shaking and
dancing like crazy like screaming in
pain
and all they see is like there's like
this guy going like
and then a thunderstorm happens and
they're like rain dance
rain dance mm-hmm yeah it's just crap
and the old guy's like no no it's a crab
he like you know his picture in my butt
when i sat down and they're like we saw
this guy dance and then it rained man
it's brain powers we saw a pattern we
had to go with it that's right
curtis b says nightly convo in short tim
the left says i'm right the right some
left
ian what happened my vibration was
focused on the fed
lids yes amazing josie i'm a lil libert
lil libertarian and honey badger
there you go that's summarized the whole
thing i know exactly who that is that's
the whole thing
how do you feel about breaking up the
federal reserve josie um i think ron
paul should do it with his bare hands
and his baseball bat
all right richard carlson says did you
snatch the ark idea from
doom and combine it with the story line
of titan ae lol
no i'm talking about um like noah's ark
i'm just making a sci-fi version of it
that a bunch of people had to build a
giant ship to escape a giant flood
and took two of each animal with them
and that's it
so michael brogan says tim your venus
arc project sounds like spoilers horizon
zero dawn which would be awesome
horizon zero dawn is amazing it's an
excellent video game
uh and it's similar those aren't
familiar there's a
self-replicating ai that is of basically
stripping out organic matter and turning
it to machines
and they realize they can't stop it at
this point and it's going to wipe out
all organic life on the planet
so instead of trying to save the plant
what they do is they bury in these
big laboratories machines that will
terraform the planet back
after the original ai dies out because
if there's no more matter left
then they'll have the activation of a
new ai that starts rebuilding so there's
robotic deer like robotic bears
trying to recreate the ecosystem and
then machines start cloning humans and
then they're born and then society
emerges
and so they're all like very tribal but
they have like remnants of ancient
technology
yeah it's crazy stuff good game the
game's fun too really really
what's really amazing about it in my
opinion is that
it's a new unique gameplay where you got
a bow and arrow but you're fighting
robots
so how do you actually br like take out
a robot with a bow and arrow hitting
key points and like breaking panels off
and then damaging the
you know critical components it's a
brilliant game really good stuff
all right see jeffrey perrine says
battlestar galactica was called adam's
arc
very much like your theory i want to
help you make art and show what's
uh and show what's a good email to reach
you
um i don't know for pitches we have jobs
at timcast.com which is probably not the
best but it's probably the best for now
it's just really difficult to get uh to
that point to start
taking on you know legit full pitches
and stuff so i guess you can try jobs at
tempest.com
chad dovey says hey tim and cass i've
been writing a comic and just found the
money to pay an artist i was wondering
if i could send you guys my first comic
love what you do and thank you yes at
timcast.com
i think in the contact section yeah
there's like a there's a po box
you can send whatever you'd like send us
uh things so long as it's appropriate i
suppose
it goes it goes it goes to a mailbox
austin scott says the epa has been
raiding aftermarket car shops and
finding
finding vehicles that are track only
they may have no cats but the past but
they pass emissions
see lund racing's youtube video look
into the rpm act it means so much
interesting yeah second time i heard
about that
frank perez says timmy should have
allison morrow on she used to work for
network news and now does youtube videos
consider it
i will look into that individual i'm not
super familiar with her
just jenny says shout out to trevor hey
trevor we were pretty sure we were
pretty mean to you now but
we're cool it's not personal we're all
we're all we're all friends i love you
trevor
actually repels now he can hang here
daniel rodriguez says
did everyone know that tim skateboards
now you do you do whoa
there was a funny there was a funny
thing on twitter where someone was like
i bet simple doesn't even really
skateboard he probably just pretends
and i've got videos that have like so my
buddy brett novak
and i always always shout out his
channel it's youtube.com says magic and
then he was matches me messages me
because he's like all of a sudden i saw
a bunch of subscribers or something what
is it youtube account what
bragic b-r-a-g-i so there's a bunch of
videos there's one from when i was 19.
it's one of the first videos uploaded to
youtube it's from
like it was recorded december of 2005 or
something
and it's one of the first videos on
youtube youtube i guess it's me skating
in a warehouse
i'm like 19 and it did it had a few
thousand views
and then because my name's at timpool a
day is warehouse
now it has like a half a million i love
that it's just it's a super old video
that youtube keeps recommending to
people
what is time yeah yeah but then i have a
couple clips from them that are like
legit like one's a nollie half hard flip
late flip and one's a hang ten hard flip
and then at the end i do a hanging hard
flip late flip so it's all there
we actually did film one years ago which
was a full hangton hardflip
late flip segment but i just too hard to
do it's like a legit hard trick
not deep fake no legit yeah real
real trick yeah i got all the wacky
tricks in the book all the weird stuff a
lot of people don't want to play skate
with me back in the day
because you're too good because i do
because like
everybody can do kick flip nollie flip
switch flip fakie flip
it's like all the basic tricks and so i
would watch people play skate
and i would do like i've i did a few of
the s game of skate like back in the day
like competitions
and it would be like the guy the person
i'm up against is like really good he'd
be like i'm gonna do a pop shove it
now i'm gonna do a switch pop shove it
now i'm gonna do a front side chubby and
i'm like dude this is
so boring and a waste of our time
because we both know we can do all of
these tricks
you're just hoping i make a mistake on a
basic trick
so i'm like i'll tell you what i was
playing skate against one dude and i did
a trick it's called the hang ten hard
flip and the dude immediately looked at
the judge and was like dude come on and
the judge was like
it's we only said like he did a trick
and i'm like i know
these people can't do these tricks so if
i can get five tricks that i can
never mess up i will win in five in five
minutes you talking about the video game
you guys no no
oh skate playing skate is where you do a
trick and your opponent has to do the
same trick oh
if they don't do it they get a letter um
so if i would do i would do uh cancel
flips
so you do a kickflip and then you use
your heel flip to make it go the other
direction
nobody knew what that was at the time i
could do all the different light flips
so it was always just like
forward flip hanging hard flip nolly
nolly half hard flip
underflip heel cancel flip and then it's
like
i win in five tricks i'm done i show up
i do the tricks i win and they just look
at me like okay
and i'm like yeah i know you can't do
those tricks i'm trying to win i'm not
trying to sit here for an hour
doing pop shove it's man but anyway i
digress nombot says from champaign
illinois love you guys and tng is indeed
the best
all right we'll do uh one last super
chat right here
let's see how do you pronounce that myth
oh mythic rogue
shallower says hey ian do you know
bill's bill hicks
young man on acid joke no bill bill
hicks
young man an acid joke i don't know that
one i like young men just
in general as people and i and i like
acid
ergot or gotta mean it comes from
lysergic acid
fungus so roosevelt media news says
police see international news reports
about strange
fibers in the disposable face masks
what is that about i didn't see much
about it but we'll look into it we will
my friends maybe we will look into it
it'll appear at timcast.com in an
exclusive members-only segment which
will be up in about an hour or so so
make sure you go to timcast.com become a
member
we're we're legit like i'm i'm saying
this is going to be like a full-on
streaming service man
it's not just going to be like talk
radio or whatever it's going to be shows
movies documentary series and we're
going to start making a ton of awesome
stuff
so if you're a member and it's like 10
bucks a month i'm going to use the money
that we get from you guys to keep making
stuff i'm not interested in infinity
pools
i'm not going to buy a spaceship or
anything like that i'm not going to
build an ironman suit i'm going to make
cultural content that is good for
everybody that's fun that's entertaining
and exciting with new superheroes new
concepts with interesting stories
i'll tell you this check out my music
video will of the people
it is an original song i wrote and an
original concept for a video
a lot of people seem to like it maybe
you'll like it but i think it's a really
great story and we got it animated and
so this is an example of some of the
stuff we want to make
which i think you'll actually get you'll
get a kick out of
so uh that being said make sure you
subscribe to this channel because we're
very close to 1 million subscribers and
with your help we will all make google
give us big shiny golden plaques and
then everyone will get one and we'll
hang them up and it'll be great
and uh hit the notification bell share
the show if you really do like it that's
the best thing you can do
and whenever you like and comment it
helps because you're telling youtube
like hey this is a good show we like
interacting with it
you can follow me on social media tim
cast my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday the friday at 8 00 p.m
so of course we will be back tomorrow
tomorrow's gonna be fun because we for
sure have uh
brandon brandon tatum we normally don't
announce guests because then we get a
cancellation it's kind of a bummer but
that's going to be an excellent show
i think we could talk a lot about cops
yeah guns this is perfectly timed
yeah so i'm super excited that he's
coming and uh josie do you have anything
you want to mention before we go
um you can follow me i i
i have a new page you can follow me at
the
t-r-h-l-t that's t-h-e-t-r-h-l
and i'd love to see you all again i've
missed everybody
it's like atm machine yes yes pretty
much
yeah right automated transaction machine
machine
pin number teller machine machine um
thank you for clarifying thank you josie
for coming you guys call
and crossland.net you can check out all
my socials from there and um
shout out to all the elements on the
periodic i don't know
from what we came and there we go yes
that's great i love it
i want to shout out the elements on the
periodic table why have i never thought
of doing that before
that's wonderful thank you ian for that
thought i'm sour patch lids on twitter
and mines and real sour patch lids on
gab and instagram
we will see you all over at the
timcast.com exclusive members only
segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you